WILL COME TO ORDER- GOOD
AFTERNOON- IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS. TO THE EXTENT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY- ALL IN THE-
WHICH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED N
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT PHONE
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AGAIN.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SIX FIVE FOUR.
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN AGAIN. SIX
FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. BUT WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TELEPHONE TESTIMONY OTHERWISE
IT WILL BE HARD PRESSED TO HEAR
YOU- AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CARE FOR YOU. FROM YOU-
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS A CUT IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE.
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENCE. TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA WHICH WE WILL HEAR. AN
FILE ORDER. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS OF THE BILLS- WE
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE
ON TIME SO WE CAN. ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- AND SO- WHAT THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE- CALL THE
ROLL TO SEARCH FORM. SENATOR
WINNER PRESENT UNDER BETH HERE.
UNDER CORTESE YOUR- HONOR
CABALLERO PRESENT A CHOIR. A
SHOW ABOUT HERE SKINNER. I'M
WOOD COUNTY HERE. OKAY SO
CENTER MCGUIRE WILL BE
RECEIVING THE MIKE REQUIRE
AWARD WHICH IS AWARDED TO THE
MEMBER WHO ARISING COMMITTEE
LOSS OF CONGRATULATIONS TO
CENTER MCGUIRE FOR ONE THING
AND ONE OF OUR- VIA A QUORUM
HAS BEEN A STOP- AND BEFORE WE
HEAR OUR FIRST BILL AND- TO
FIRST. ADOPT OUR COMMITTEE
RULES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO LEGISLATIVE
SESSION- IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO THE COMMITTEE RULES- WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE RULES ARE.
ADOPTED OKAY WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR THAT IS
ITEM NUMBER ONE. SENATE BILL
FIFTEEN- AND SENATOR PORTANTINO
IS HERE TO- PRESENTS WELCOME
SENATOR THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING SP
FIFTEEN WHICH WILL GIVE
INCENTIVES TO CITIES THAT
CONVERT ABANDONED RETAIL SITES
INTO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
CIVICALLY SB FIFTEEN WILL
ENABLE LOCAL CITIES TO RECEIVE
FROM H. E. B. THE AVERAGE OF
THE ANNUAL. TAX REVENUE
GENERATED BY THAT SITE FOR THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS- IF THAT SITE
HAS BEEN CONVERTED IN OCCUPIED
WITH NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THESE FISCAL INCENTIVES WILL BE
USED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REPLACE THE SALES TAX REVENUE
LOSS FROM THE CLOSURE. OF THESE
BE BY BIG BOX RETAIL STORES
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THE WAY WE
MONETISE LAND USE IT
INCENTIVIZES RETAIL OVER
HOUSING AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FLIP THAT CONTRACT CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING EMERGENCY ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. FROM TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AT TWO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE PROXIMALLY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION NEW HOUSING
UNITS ARE NEEDED TO MEET THE
PROJECTED POPULATION AND
HOUSING GROWTH OR HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND NEW HOMES
ANNUALLY. THE IMBALANCE BETWEEN
SUPPLY AND DEMAND IS DRIVEN
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING COSTS BE
THE HIGHEST IN THE NATION WITH
AN AVERAGE MEDIAN HOME PRICE
OF. NAP TWO POINT FIVE TIMES
THAT OF THE US MEDIA. THESE
HIGH PRICES HAVE PROHIBITED
OCCUPANTS LIKE TEACHERS NURSES
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS AND
YOUNGER PROFESSIONALS THE
ABILITY TO AFFORD OWNING A HOME
ESSENTIAL FOR BUILDING A STRONG
AND VIBRANT ECONOMY. A CURRENT
TREND HAS EMERGED IN LOCAL
ECONOMICS DUE TO THE GROWTH OF
E-COMMERCE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN NATIONAL RETAILERS
HAVE BEEN REDUCING THEIR DEMAND
FOR FUTURE SPACE AND RETAIL
CENTERS AND ARE CLOSING STORES.
THEY'RE BANNING THESE RETAIL
SITES AT A PACE GREATER THAN
EVEN DURING THE GREAT RECESSION
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A
MAJOR ISSUE FOR CURRENT AND
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES IN
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTIES. HOUSING
AN INCH TRANSLITERATED IS
INTRINSICALLY. CONNECTED TO THE
WELFARE OF OUR POPULATION AND
BUSINESS. LACKING TO ATTAINED
HOUSING EMPLOYEE WORK
ENVIRONMENTS SUFFER AND THE
GREATER ECONOMY IS NEGATIVELY
IMPACT. NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON LAND FORMERLY USED BY
COMMERCIAL RETAILERS. GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF FISCAL
INCENTIVES. TO ENCOURAGE
REZONING APPROVING AND
COMPLETING IT ALLOWING
OCCUPANCY OF WORKFORCE HOUSING
PROJECTS. WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE
CHRIS WILSON FROM BIZ FED AND
ERIN LEHANE WITH THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADE
TRADES COUNCIL TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO WILL NOT HEAR
FROM OUR LEAD WITNESSES IN
FAVOR STARTING WITH CHRIS
WILSON- BOB FROM BUSINESS-
COOPER. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COME BEFORE YOU TODAY MY
NAME IS CHRIS WILSON ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION KNOWN AS BATES SAID
WE ARE GRASSROOTS ALLIANCE THE
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
DIVERSE BUSINESS GROUPS
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYERS WITH OVER
FOUR MILLION EMPLOYEES. IN L.
A. COUNTY THE ADVOCATES FOR
POLICIES AND PROJECTS THAT
STRENGTHEN OUR REGIONAL ECONOMY.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK THE
REPORT. FOR BRINGING IMPORT
MEASURE FOR. LAST YEAR AS YOUR
AS YOUR MY MEMBER BATES SAID.
SB NINE NINE. VICTOR WE ARE
GRANDSTANDING WITH THE COURT AS
KEY SO OF SB FIVE. THERE'S NO
THAT SB FIFTY AT THE END OF A
SOLUTION MAGGIE. LOCAL GO SINCE
TO ALLOW FOR MORE HOUSING. IN
THEIR CHURCH. AND TO MAKE REAL
STRIDES IN INCREASING HOUSING
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA THAT
MAKES THE SHARE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S HOUSING GOALS.
CHURCH MEMBERS OUR STATE IS IN
A HOUSING CRISIS. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. FIFTY
EIGHT POINT FIVE APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION NEW
HOUSING UNITS. ARE NEEDED TO BE
PROJECTED POPULATION AND
HOUSEHOLD GROWTH. IT'S ALSO
ALARMING TO KNOW THAT AS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTY
NINE OUT OF FIFTY IN HOMES PER
CAPITA. CALIFORNIA'S THE DEER
HOUSING SHORTAGE NEED CREATED
FINANCIALLY VIABLE PROPOSALS TO
TACKLE THIS CHALLENGE. SB
FIFTEEN PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON LAND FORMERLY USED BY
COMMERCIAL RETAILERS AND GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FISCAL
INCENTIVES AS A REWARD FOR
REZONING. APPROVING COMPLETELY
AND ALLOW THE OCCUPANCY OF
HOUSING PROJECTS. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BILLS SPREAD
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTED BODY
SUPPORT OF S. FIFTY TO PROVIDE
LOCAL THAT. THEY NEED TO
INCREASE HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA. GREAT TIME AND WE
HAVE ANSWERING YOU MAY. I THANK
YOU FOR MUCH I I'M GOING TO MY
THE BEGINNING OF HOW WE COM
SHEETS OF THE LEE WITNESS. WITH
THE TO. PRO TO WITNESS PRO TO
BE WHEN BECAUSE- EACH WILL HAVE
TOO MANY- THEN FOR OTHER. IT'LL
BE SIMPLY YOUR- AFFILIATE. YOUR
NAME YOUR- IF ANY AND WHETHER
USE OF. OR OPPOSE A SORE NECK.
WITNESS IN LEAVING AS A SUPPORT
OF ARE IN MY A FROM THE-
BUILDING THANKS FOR TRADES. BUT
AFTER. SENATOR WIENER AND
MEMBER OF THE SAN HOUSING
COMMITTEE. I APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY ON THE OF DISTRICT I.
INTERNET BROTHER OF BOYS. AND
THEN YOU'RE HAPPENED MEMBERS.
OF THE STATE BUILDING A TRADES
CAL. IN PRO SUPPORT- CENTER
BILL FIFTY. WE'RE TO SUPPORT
THE L. ONE AGAIN WERE WITH
SENATOR PORTENT. THIS BILL DOES
TWO VERY IMPORTANT THINGS IT
PUTS PEOPLE TO WORK AND TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR WORKING
PEOPLE. TWO THINGS THAT WE DE
NOW MAYBE MORE THAN EVER IS OUR
STATE REBOUNDS FROM THE COBIT
PANDEMIC. WE ARE GRATEFUL TO
CENTER PORTANTINO FIRST
PARTNERSHIP AND THE DRAFTING
THE BILL TO INCLUDE PROVISIONS
RELATING TO FAIR WAGES. AND THE
USE OF A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. THE BUILDING TRADES
CURRENTLY HAVE SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND APPRENTICES ACROSS THE
STATE. ORDING TO THE DA ARE 72%
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR AND ONE IN
FIVE THAT'S FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE COME FROM FOSTER CARE
EMANCIPATED USE OR THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP PROVIDES A
LIFETIME PROFESSION AND A PATH
TO THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR NON
COLLEGE BOUND CALIFORNIANS.
BILLS LIKE SB FIFTEEN ONCE
PASSED WILL NOT ONLY CREATE
MUCH NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STATEWIDE BUT WILL ALSO CREATE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUNG HARD WORKING CALIFORNIANS
TO LEARN A TRADE AND EARN A
LIVING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIFTEEN
THANK YOU MISTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU MISS LANE WILL NOW GO
TO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
WHICH AGAIN WILL INSTANCE
CONSISTS OF TEN YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THEN-
SUPPORT AND THEN LATER
OPPOSITION- SO WILL NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE- I SEE ONE
PUBLIC COMMENTER. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
SEE NO ADDITIONAL COM. HERE AND
FOR TWO OR THREE. WE WILL NOW
GO TO- ROOM TWENTY FORTY I SEE
NO ONE. IN TWENTY FORTY WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES- WILL
THE OPERATOR- PLEASE SIGNAL FOR
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT. THEY GIVE
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
OVER TO THE FIRST LINE OF ONE
SIX I WON YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE
WILL NOW GO TO DISH DOT COM OR
CALL BACK WHICH IS THAT WHAT
I'M LINE ONE SIX ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ARE COMMON FOR AT. TEN
OKAY ALL COMMENTS NO IS A
SPEAKER TO SO YOU'RE NOT A
SPEAKER- YOU SHOULD YOU IT IS
TO EARLY. THE NEXT WILL COME TO
LINE- OF WAR THAT ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS JOE
SPAULDING I THE CAR IN YOUR
MARKET BILL TRADES. AND WE ARE
JOINED THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL IN THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
FIFTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WELL I OF ONE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR TURN MEMBERS OF
YOUR TOTAL STRONG BEHALF OF THE
OF MONICA AND OF IT. THANK YOU
I'M M. MADAM OPERATED FOR HAS
COME CALLERS DO WE HAVE INSTEAD.
OUR RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A FORTY
EIGHT. FORTY IN SUPPORT FORTY
EIGHT IN SUPPORT OKAY WERE FIVE
DUE TO THE PANDA WE HAVE- TIME
ON IT IS HERE. AND SO WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO ACCEPT
A FORTY EIGHT FIVE CALLERS
EITHER OR CON WE'RE GOING TO
SET LIMITS. ON BOTH OF OVER DO
IS THE FOR FIFTEEN INFILL AND
THE FIRST- AND THEN OTHERS KIND.
COMMENTS THROUGH SENATE WHAT
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING TO
DO THIS BUT WE ARE LIVING AND-
UNIQUE AND DIFFICULT TIMES AND-
WE'RE- NOT JUST TO SORT OF
HELLO UNFORTUNATELY. OUR
PROCESS IS WORKING THESE DAYS-
SO MADAM OPERATOR IF YOU COULD-
THAT WAS ONE WILL DO THAT
ANOTHER FOURTEEN UNTIL WE GOT.
THANK YOU THE NEW TIME WILL
COME LINE ONE EIGHTY YEAR OF
THE- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MAY CLEMENT BE
HAPPEN CAL ABOUT A CAR ABOUT
ENGINEERS. WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTER SB FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A LINE OF
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR OF THE-
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE REMEMBER
THIS IS EVAN OF CARBON LOCAL TO
USE. IN COUNTY. STRONG SOME
SENATE BILL FIFTY THANK YOU.
THANK NEXT LINE OF ONE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE OF THE- MR
MEMBERS RYAN WE GALA CITY THAT
WE ARE STRONGER BY. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR MEMBERS%
YOUR ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT OF IT. THANK YOU
MICHAEL OF NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON THIS IS
AUGIE BELCHER WITH THE
CARPENTERS CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN EXTRA
LINE OF TO ALL THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS TRULY
TAPPED THE COUNCILMEMBER FOR
THE CITY OF PLEASANTON. M.
HELLO LINE OF LOCAL ELECT WE
ARE IN TRONG. HELLO OF TWO OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE OF OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN RANDOM ON THE OF THE
AGE HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND
HELP HOUSING. IN SUPPORT OF THE
AT WE OUT IN OUR TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
FOUR YOUR LINE OF OPEN. YES
NAME IS DAVID NOW I'M THE
INTERNET BROUGHT OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND WE WERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE AWAY SEVENTY
FIVE AIRLINERS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PATRICK HELLO ARE AND
LOCAL THREE STROKES. THANK YOU
CAN TO A LINE OF FIFTY THREE
LINE OF THE- ERIN BURNED I'M
WITH THE MOTHER HE DOES. AND WE
HAVE STRONG OUTREACH AND WE ARE
OR- THANK YOU. X. OF A LINE OF
WHAT ONE THREE LINE OF THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT NEED SKEW
SO PRESENTING LOOKS HEAT
PROCESS. AND WE'RE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF THE
LINE OF ONE SIX FOUR YEAR LINE
OPEN. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
CARRERO. THE LAST CA DIVISION
OF BELIEVE COUNSEL CITIES IF
THE CITIES IN THE CAN.
CONFOUNDS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ROBSON
NAMBI HALF SHE WORKERS LOCAL
ONE FOR. WE JOIN THE STATE
BUILDING AND SO OF THIS BECAUSE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF NINETY ONE YOUR AS WELL.
I KING KHAN ON B. OF THE
COMMUTER AT LAMAR PART AND THIS
DIDN'T TELL STRONG. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR FIFTEEN OF OUR
COME A TO A FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- GET UP JOHN DOE I BE LOW
SIX THE CENSUS GO BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WANTS SO OF THE BECAUSE- THANK
YOU AND A TOUR. GOD CONSULTANT
HOW WITH THAT ARE WE GOT FIFTY
UNDER ONE ONE MORE OR IS THAT
FIFTEEN. DOES WOULD FIFTEEN
OKAY SO THAT WAS A GOOD SO.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
CALLED THE YOU CAN SUBMIT-
WRITTEN AND- TO THE SENATE
WANTS- SO. WE WILL NOW- TO
OFFER- IF ANY. TO FIFTEEN WE
HAVE NO WITH AND ALL- IS OR
ANYONE ELSE. HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- TO. SAYING NINE IS THERE.
IN OFFICE AND TWENTY. SEEING
NINE MATTER OPERATED WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE AND I. TO
ASK YOU TO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
APPLE. YOU MIGHT ONE AND THEN
ZERO NOW. AND OUR FIRST CALLER
WILL COME FROM ONE OF ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS A PROJECT MANAGER
I'M WITH THE HYDE PARK
ORGANISERS PARTNERSHIP FOR
EMPOWERMENT AND- SHALL LA COULD
JUST. AND WE- HOMES TO. SB
FIFTEEN AS IT STANDS APART OF
THE REASON IS BECAUSE OUR
COMMERCIAL. IS BEING ERODED
RIGHT NOW HI HOUSING. WHICH IS
B. FIFTEEN WITH WE HAD LIKE
LIMITED AND OF. HOW ABOUT HOW
WITH THE- WE CAN NO HAVE THE
RIGHT ANY MORE HOW PROJECT NOT.
CORRIDOR THE HOUSING PROJECT
ALONG NOT CORRIDOR. TOTALLY
GIVEN ROAD. OUR COMMERCIAL
CORRIDOR AND WE NEED. BY A AND
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR-
IF THEY TO ASSIST ITSELF. SO
FOR THAT REASON I WOULD BE UP.
JEW TOP OF SB FIFTEEN BUT WE
AMENDMENTS WE WOULD SHOULD SB
THREE. THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
TAKE THAT AS A LEAD WITH.
AGAINST FIVE MEN OPERATOR HOW
MAY- ADDITIONAL CALLERS AN
OPERA. TO FIFTY. THEIR NEW IN
Q. AT THIS BUT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. HAVE OPPOSITE YOU MAY
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE IN THERE
PROPER. AND ONE MORE WE HAVE
TWO MORE UP LET ME GET THEIR
LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT.
BUT
OPERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COLORS. YEP ONE
MOMENT. AND THAT FIRST LINE
WILL COME FROM WIND TO TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
AGAIN THIS IS NAME IS IN THE-
NAME OF PHILLY OPPOSE ON FOR.
MY IS ANDRE STORE AND I AM AS
LIVING IN THE CITY OF SAN
OPPOSED TO FIFTEEN I THINK
BECAUSE OF THE CLOSE PRICE. OF
PEOPLE IN BECAUSE OF IT COVER
VIRUS WITH AGAIN SICK AND-
TRANCE THE THEN THIS IS A
BETWEEN EACH OTHER AND THIS
THING THAT THE THAT YOU'RE A
FIFTY ASSEMBLY GOING TO. THE
GOOD NEWS FOR MORE I THINK A
TERRIBLE IDEA AND THEY'RE ALL
TO THAT THE. COOPER WE SHOULD
BE CAN. AS A VARIETY AND I.
FROM THE STAMP OF SAYS OF THOSE
MOST PEOPLE BUT I. OUR AGAINST
IT YOU'VE GOT ALL THE TRADE
UNIONS AND KALRA P. SWITCH FOR
IT BUT NONE OF THE P. WHO WERE
ARE THE- ARE FOR IT. OKAY I
THANK YOU THAT WAS WILL TAKE
THAT AS THIS MIDWAY AND FORWARD
WE WILL. NAME AND OPPOSITE.
FIVE IS THERE ANY ELSE- MADAM-
OPERATOR. YES WE HAVE TO AND
THAT FILED FROM ONE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORE. I'M
RON MILLER EXECUTIVES. OF THE
A. ORANGE BILL BECAUSE TRADE
COUNCIL. ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDRED FORTY TO. MEN AND WOMEN
THAT LIVE LOSS SAID. HEY TAXES.
AND LIVE A THE AREA THAT WOULD
BENEFIT WE ARE AND- OF BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FIVE. ANY
OTHER OP. THIS IS TIME FOR
OPPOSITE ONLINE. YES THAT'LL
COME FROM ONE OF ONE TWENTY
FIVE LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HELLO
NINE ONE TWO FIVE AIRLINE OPEN.
ALL RIGHT. OKAY AND WE'LL MOVE
ON TO THE LINE OF TWO FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ROBERT SMITH
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES SAW
STRONG EXTREMELY STRONG SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU AGAIN THIS IS A TIME
FOR OPPOSITION ONLY SUPPORT-
IT'S PAST. TIME IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND THE
LAST ONE IN Q. MISTER CHAIR IS
LINE. ONE TWENTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
TRANSAMERICA'S WITH YOU
CALIFORNIA- NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
STANDING INVOLUNTARY IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY OKAY THANK
YOU- BARBARA HOW MANY. ARE IN
QUEUE. WE HAVE NO ONE FURTHER
IS KNOWN FOR OTHER AT ALL OKAY
GREAT- SO THAT CONCLUDES PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES OTHER
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR TROUBLED. MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK. I HAVE
CONCERNS TODAY WITH SB FIFTEEN
BECAUSE OF ITS RESTRICTIVE
NATURE. IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
ENCOURAGE AND CREATE
LEGISLATION THAT ENSURES EQUAL
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
LIMITING THE WORKFORCE WAS
ALLEGED ELIGIBLE FOR THESE
GRANTS UNDERMINES CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR EVERYONE TO HAVE A CHANCE
AT ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
MOBILITY AND HAS THE CAPACITY
TO INCREASE HOUSING COSTS AS
MUCH AS 10215% AS A STATE WHO
SEEKS TO BE A LEADER OF THE
NATION WE MUST STRIVE TO UPHOLD
INCLUSIVITY AND REMOVE THE
BARRIERS THAT KEEP SO MANY FROM
HAVING A SEAT AT THE TABLE. I
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO MOVE
AWAY FROM BENEFIT IN THE FEW AT
THE COST OF MANY. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY GOING TO
BE OPPOSING- THIS BILL UNLESS
WE HAVE AN AMENDMENT WITH WHICH
INCLUDES EVERYONE'S ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS- ENDEAVOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FIVE
FEDERAL. B. SOUTHERN ALICE'S I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR CITIES TO TAKE THE
ACTION THE ACTION THAT THEY
TAKE IS THAT CREATE A BY RIGHT-
DEVELOPMENT- ON THIS ON THESE
COMMERCIAL PARCELS YEAH I THINK.
YEAH I BELIEVE THE ONLY THING
WERE WERE WERE EXPECTING DESIGN
REVIEW BUT IT'S ALSO A
COMPLIMENARY OF MISCARRY
ARROWS BILL AS WELL SO I THINK
THEY WORK IN CONCERT TOGETHER
BUT THIS IS JUST THE FUNDING
IT'S NOT THE THIS IS CREATING A
GRANT PROGRAM OKAY- GOOD. ANY
OTHER QUITE CENTER. I DO AGREE
WITH THAT SENATOR PORTANTINO IT
IS COMPLEMENTARY AND WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE I WILL MOVE THE
BILL. I'LL TAKE THAT AS A
MOTION. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES. OKAY I
SING NINE- THIS- THE BILL
DOESN'T HI I AM IT AYE VOTE
THIS BILL I WANT TO THANK
CENTER FOR HIS WORK- AND WITH
THAT WE WERE MOTION AND CENTER
FOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
RESPECTFULLY I FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK- WILL
CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE ON FIVE
AND THE MOTION IS TIED PASSED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THIS WHICH I
HEAR OF VERY VERY TOUGH CHAIR.
YEAH THIS IS SENATE BILL
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR PORTENT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WINNER.
BY WHERE I'D BATES I'M NOT
VOTING AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT HI I'M DEFERRING MY
BILL TO APPROPRIATIONS BECAUSE
I HAD A QUICK QUESTION I MISS
THE OPPORTUNITY. SO I WILL
FOLLOW UP WHEN WE GET TO
PERHAPS. BATES NOT VOTING
CABALLERO I ZERO FIVE CORTES I
FORTY I'D MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE I'D
ACCIONES NO THE CHARBONEAU
SKINNER. SKINNER I AM BURKE- BY
CAL SKI BY THE CAST HIGH. SOME
A ONE. OKAY THE- THE ARE SEVEN
AND OR WHY OF THE MOST- PASSES
ORDERED THE BILL TO. OKAY WELL
NUMBER TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
THREE FORTY- BY HERTZBERG-
HERTZBERG PLEASE CONFIRM. OKAY.
MUSKRAT. WELCOME FOR HERTZBERG
VENTURE YOU PLEASE PRESENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE OF THE-
MOST IS WERE FOR IN SOCIETY AT
THIS TIME ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
FACING HOMELESSNESS. LOCAL
COUNTY. FOR OF US THE STATE
FEDERAL LEVEL OR PULLING HER
HAIR OUT TRYING TO IT OUT.
PEOPLE STILL. LIVE IN THE
STREET. HIS THIS ONE SENATOR TO
A WOMAN THE SIDE AT THE LOG
FOR. IT EXTRAORDINARILY.
CHALLENGING AT EVERY LOW AND HE
WILL ARE GOING. PEOPLE MAD AS
HELL AT US WE'RE NOT SOLVING
THE- AND THERE. WE GET A FOR
OUT. TO ONE OF THOSE. OF ALL
THE WHICH WHICH SAW THE-
PORTER'S REPORT THIRTY POINT
ONE BILLION THE OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS THAT WE SPENT IN
WHAT IMPACT IS THAT. COMMITTEE
I REPRESENT LOS ANGELES IS MORE
HOMELESS PEOPLE THAN WE HAD
BEFORE. WHO CARES WHAT THE
REASONS ARE YOU GONNA SOLVE IT.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE BEFORE TODAY
IS A CONTINUATION OF THE
PROGRAM THAT I STARTED. WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN I THINK IT WAS
TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. I
GOT THIS FROM A FRIEND OF MINE
ACTUALLY NEVER TO QUIT WORK. I
DON'T DESERVE IT. BUT YOU SEE
SO MANY PEOPLE WON'T GOING TO
SHELTERS BECAUSE THEY GOT A
PATH SO MOST IMPORTANT THING
ANNA DUGGAR CADDO ALL KINDS OF
PETS. AND SO WE STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN A PROGRAM
THAT WAS DRAMATICALLY OVER
SUBSCRIBED FOR FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH DOESN'T HAVE AN
APPROPRIATION TO IT YET BUT
GIVEN THE SURPLUS THAT WE HAVE
AMASSED FOR. TON OF MONEY. TO
ABLE TO PROVIDE SPECIAL FOR
PEOPLE'S PETS AND IF YOU COULD
TAKE CARE OF THEIR PETS AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE LINE. BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT THEY'LL- THEY'LL GOING
TO SHELTER THE COME OFF THE
STREET BUT THEY'RE NOT COMING
OFF THE STREET LEAVING THEIR
PETS BEHIND. THAT ISSUE TO
PORTANTINO. TO FOR VERY LITTLE
MONEY. WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT ON BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH IF YOU WILL NOT JUST FOR
THE PATS BUT FOR THE HUMAN
BEINGS. THAT FIND THEMSELVES ON
THE STREET. AND HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT AND REDUCING PEOPLE TO
FIX PRICING HOMELESSNESS BOTH
SIDES. TO THE SETS OF THE
PROGRAM WE INITIALLY STARTED
WE- ULTIMATELY JUST PUT IT IS A
BUDGET REQUEST. IN TWO THOUSAND
I THINK IT WAS NINETEEN. BUT
IT'S A WAY TO FUNDAMENTALLY
DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGES WE
DEAL WITH HOMELESSNESS ON THE
ONE HAND. AND ON THE OTHER
HAND. IT IS VERY HUMANE AND TO
VOTE FOR THE PET AND FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL A DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
TAKING CARE OF BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH. GENTLENESS TESTIFYING
TODAY CAN. PRESIDENT HOPE
WITHOUT RESCUE MISSION THE CITY
IN SAN FERNANDO VALLEY RIGHT
WHERE I HAIL FROM. WHO RECENTLY
WAS DESIGNATED HERTZBERG HERO
FOUR EXTRAORDINARY WORK. IN
THIS AND SO MANY OTHER FIELDS
TO TALK ABOUT. THE SUCCESS OF
THIS PROGRAM BEFORE. AND WHY
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE PARTICULARLY NOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG WE WILL HAVE
YOUR LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS
TESTIFYING DOWN THAT'S BEEN
STRICKEN. HOPE OF THE VALLEY
RESCUE MISSION. HI MY NAME CAN
I AM THE FOUNDER AND- AT ABOUT
RESCUE MISSION AND WE WERE
PARTICIPANTS IN THE INITIAL
PHASE OF THE- PROGRAM AND
FUNDAMENTALLY I SUPPORT IS
BECAUSE- I SEE EVERY DAY. BE A
OF BERRIER THAT COULD PEOPLE
GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED. SOME OF THE BARRIERS ARE
VERY DIFFICULT TO OVERCOME WHEN
YOU HAVE SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
AND I NAY REQUIRE POLITICS
POLICY CHANGES BUT ONE OF THE
LOCAL BARRIERS THAT WE CAN
ADDRESS AND DEAL WITH HAD TO DO
WITH PEOPLE AT. JUST RECENTLY
WE HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF OPENING
WITH THE LOCAL COUNCILMEN THE
VERY FIRST TINY HOME COMMUNITY
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE EIGHT DOGS THAT LIVE THERE
WITH HEIR OWNERS. AND THE FACT
THAT THEY COULD COME IN IN THE
DOGS COULD STAY WITH THEM AND
LIVE WITH THEM IT WAS A GAME
CHANGER. WE HAVE ONE GENTLEMEN
WHO HAS BEEN HOMELESS EVERSENSE
THE NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE HAD
NEVER COME INSIDE AND HE WAS
ABLE TO COME INSIDE WHICH IS
PAT AND NOW WE'RE ABLE TO WORK
WITH THEM OFFER THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COUNSELING AND OPENLY GET
THEM INTO PERMANENT HOUSING. SO
TODAY AS ONE WHO HAD BEEN THE
BENEFICIARY AT HELPING DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
HAVE HAD IN BEING ABLE TO HELP
BOTH PEOPLE ON BOTH ENDS OF THE
LEASH I. FULL HEARTEDLY SUPPORT
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY FOUR-
AND I THINK SENATOR HERTZBERG
AND THE TEAM FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER AND HOPE THAT IT WILL
PASS OF THE WE CONTINUE TO HELP
MORE PEOPLE- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT ARE ALMOST THAT HAVE
HAD IN THAT NEED THIS LEVEL OF
CARE FOR THEIR. FOUR LEGGED
FRIENDS. THANK YOU MISTER CROW
ON. WITNESSES AND SOME THAT
MIGHT BE. ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. TWO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
I AM LEE HANNA OF THE BILL THE
CONCERT TRADE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MISTER
HERTZBERG- EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF
THE HOMELESS AND THEIR ANIMALS
THANK YOU THANK YOU. DO YOU SEE
I DON'T SEE ANY ADDITIONAL OUR
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I DON'T SEE ANY THERE
SO WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES. AND MADAME MODERATOR THE
G. LEFT OPEN THE PHONE LINES
AND LET US KNOW HOW MANY WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
TEN IN THE QUEUE. THERE ARE
NONE NOT MAN HAS SET FIFTY UP
SO WE ARE WITHIN THAT SO PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES. IN BEGAN.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO A LOT
INTRIGUED AHEAD. THANK YOU HAVE-
THIS IS ROBINSON WAS SHOT INTO
SCHMALTZ OR ALL BEHALF OF BATES
SOCIETY OF THE U. STATES ITS
SUPPORT PERCENT HERTZBERG THANK
YOU. AND I'VE BEEN VERY FATHER
JOE'S VILLAGES IN SAN DIEGO AND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE SPELL
IT ENABLED US TO SERVE
INDIVIDUALS WITH THEIR PETS.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO ALL
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THE CHILI PEPPER BUT I COULD
PUT THE FILM. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EMILY GABEL LUDDY
BURBANK MAYOR MONTEREY WITH THE
THERAPEUTIC VALUE A PATH TO
COMPLETELY SUPPORT SB THREE
FORTY FOUR. FIVE FIVE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
WELL ONE FIVE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE'RE TRYING TO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
COMPANY ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
MARS INCORPORATED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A LINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
GREG LEWIS SO IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FORTY FOUR. SINCE THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JENNIFER HEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY
SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY AND
SAN FRANCISCO SPC IN STRONG
SUPPORT I WANT TO THANK YOU
CANNELLA HERTZBERG AND JUST
NOTE THAT THIS PROGRAM WAS OVER
SUBSCRIBED BY A 100% IN TWENTY
TWENTY SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO PROVIDE
TONS MORE FUN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT TWO ONE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I
AM THE VIRGINIA MCISAAC I'M A
PRIVATE CITIZEN AND I AM IN
FAVOR OF SB THREE FOUR FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE FOR
THE LAST IN Q. NINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL. BRIAN
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT ONE EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE ONLY AUDIBLE AND I'M
THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR IMPACT IN LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE OF THE PATENT SYSTEM
SUPPORT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN OUR SHELTER WAS ABLE
TO INCREASE. I DON'T OUR INTAKE
BY TEN FROM 10225% WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT. THREE FORTY FOUR.
THANK YOU I'M TWO THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE EVEN WHEN I WAS WITH
THE ELECT PPL WE CAN THANK THE
PORT AT ABOUT THREE TWENTY
FOUR. IF YOU HAVE THAT
FINANCIAL MEANS ARE NOT AN
INDICATION THANK YOU BOB
FRANKEN ANY ANIMAL BUT YOU VERY.
MUCH EXPECTORANT SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I'M ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES DOLLAR LEVEL- MY
WIFE AND I HAD FIVE DOLLARS ALL
THOSE. ALI FOR. FIVE DOT. FIVE
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION IF ANY TO
SB THREE FORTY FOUR- WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED- SO WE WILL- BEST OF
THOSE ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SAYING NINE
ONE ALGORITHM TWENTY FORTY ANY
OPPOSITION SEEING NINE WHEN I
GO TO THE PHONE LINES BOTTOM
OPERATOR THIRTY ONE CUED UP OR
COULD YOU QUEUE PEOPLE
PROPOSITION THE S. B. THREE
FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO FIFTEEN
HELLO KITTY IS BECAUSE OF ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY
ROBERT'S BED PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES I TRIED TO GET
INTO THE OTHER Q- I THANK THE
SENATOR HERTZBERG ANIMALS ARE
JUST SO SPECIAL AS OUR PEOPLE.
AND THE BECOME OUR CHILDREN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE FOUGHT
FOR ALMOST THIRTY CATHOLIC HOME
THANK YOU. THIRTY CAP DOGS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PROKARYOTES FARM. NEXT TIME-
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE AND THANK
YOU. THAT WOMAN. THE THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME OKAY HAVING
CATS GET OVERSHADOWED BY DOG
SOMETIMES THE CUTS ARE PRETTY
AMAZING SO- OKAY SO WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- IS
THERE ANY CAR ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON SB THREE FORTY
FOUR. SENATOR WHY CAL SKI- I
HAVE A QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE STAFF REPORT TALKS ABOUT-
THE AUTHOR HARMONIZING THIS
BILL WITH THE DEFINITION OF A
LOW BARRIER NAVIGATION CENTER
AND I DIDN'T CATCH THAT DURING.
THE PRESENTATION. AB JUST
BASICALLY BUT I DID MENTION IT
AND PRESENTATION CENTER CASKEY.
BUT BASICALLY THE IDEA IS TO IN
EVERY WAY POSSIBLE TO- WHEN WE
ARE DEALING WITH PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS TO.
ALLOW FOR PETS IN EVERY WAY
POSSIBLE THAT'S THE IDEA I
GUESS ONE OF THE THINGS AND
CLARIFICATION ON. THE TWENTY
NINETEEN AMENDMENTS BECAUSE-
YOU'RE OF A CERTAIN AGE LIKE
MYSELF THAT WE HAD DOG HOUSES
AND WE UNDERSTOOD THAT SHOULD
THERE WOULD BE A DOG AND A DOG.
HOUSE ON A RELATIVELY CHEAP
LEVEL AND I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE GRANTS THAT
WERE GIVEN. TO BE TWENTY ONE
AND TWO HUNDRED. THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IS THAT FOR THE
HOMELESS PERSON THE HOUSING THE
HOMELESS PERSON AND A DOG IN A
CO HABITATION LEVEL OR
SUSPICIOUS FOR THE- ANIMALS
BOTH THE VETERINARIANS SAY IT'S
ALSO VETERINARY SERVICES.
MAKING SURE THAT THE FACILITY
CAN BE CONVERTED TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE ANIMALS. THE VET
SERVICES AND ALL AND THE LIKE
BUT IT'S FOR BOTH IT'S
BASICALLY TO GIVE. FOLKS TODAY
HAVE THESE LIKE LIKE CAR LIKE A
CANS PLACE IN THE VALLEY THE-
HOPE OF THE VALLEY THE MONEY
NECESSARY TO BILL THAT THE
FACILITIES TO HANDLE THEM
SOMETIMES IN SOME INSTANCES THE
ANIMALS ARE SEPARATE FROM
SOMETIMES THE ANIMALS ARE RIGHT
NEXT TO. DEPENDING UPON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. OKAY THAT'S OKAY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
COLLEAGUES. BETTER CABALLERO
WITH THE BILL WE HAVE A MOTION
BOB I CENTER CARREIRO AND THAT
IS A BETTER MOTION IS TO NOT TO
PASS AS AMENDED EXCEPT THE
MINUTES INSTRUMENT YEAH THE EX
OF THE MOMENT I DIDN'T BEFORE
BUT I HAVE JUST NOW DONE SO AT
THE ADVICE OF YOUR STAFF
BECAUSE I'VE GOT TO DO WITH THE
INTRODUCTION EXCELLENT- TO THE
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS REMAIN.
ON THE TO CLARIFY CENTER WHAT
COUNTY OUR COMMITTEE DID
RECOMMEND SWEDEN INSIST ON IT
BUT WE RECOMMENDED- TO GOD THE
AUTHOR TO AMEND THE BILL TO
LIMIT APPLICANTS SHELTERS TO
THOSE IN NEED A DEFINITION OF
LOW BARRIER NAIGATION CENTER
WE DO THINK THAT THAT'S THE
BEST APPROACH HOWEVER I DO
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHORS-
PERSPECTIVE AND WE WHICH IS
RECOMMENDING THAT YOU CONSIDER
THAT MOVING FORWARD- AND WE'RE
HERE TO CONTINUE TO HELP AND
PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION OR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. WITH THAT
SAID LET'S LET'S MISTER HELLO
Y'ALL ARE YOUR CLOTHES- I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON%
THIS AS AMENDED AND I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FOR THIS IS ACTUALLY. I
THINK A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
WE'VE SEEN- YOU KNOW PEOPLE NOT
WANT TO GO INTO SHELTER BECAUSE
OF THEIR ANIMALS AND ANIMALS
ARE A CRITICAL PART OF PEOPLE'S
FAMILIES IN EXISTENCE AND SO
THIS IS A REALLY GREAT ALSO
THANK YOU CENTER FOR BRING UP
FORWARD- AND WITH THAT WE HAVE
A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YET I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN YOU WERE INVOLVED IN
THIS VERY ISSUE. WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS IN PART OF THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND LOOKING TO
LEGISLATION WORKING CALL
COLLABORATIVELY WITH OUR OFFICE
I WANT TO THANK YOU IT'S NOT
SOMETHING NEW TO YOU YOU HAVE
BEEN THE FOREFRONT OF THIS AS
WELL THAT ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
ORDER THINK JENNIFER FEARING A
WANTED TO TAKE JOHN LEVELS FIVE
DOGS ROBERT SMITH THIRTY CATS-
AND ERIN LEHANE- FOR SHOWING UP
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM FOR
THE BUILDING TRADES ALL
SURPRISES ME- THAT YOU. CAN
HAVE HER THE WHOLE SOMETIMES
BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE IT I
THINK IT'S JUST A THOUGHTFUL
WAY. TO DO THE RIGHT THING WITH
THE VERY VERY CHAO. ISSUE WE
HAVE IN OUR SOCIETY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS RELIABLE. THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW CALL. THE ROLL.
NOT CONSULTANT THIS SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY FOUR BY SEVEN HURT
THE MO IS PASS AS A MAN BU FOR
A MAN AND REAR TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATE. CENTER WINNER
FIVE WIENER I'D BATES BATES II
CABALLERO CABALLERO HI CORTESE
HI PARTISI I'D MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE A CHEWABLE I A CHEWABLE ICE
SKINNER. THEY DO X. TAKES THE
OTHER THINGS ALONG THE WAY I'VE
SEEN. SKINNER I AM BURKE. WITH
CASKEY HI THE HEALTHCARE BY
EIGHT ZERO OKAY EIGHT EIGHT
ZERO- THE MOTION PASSES- ONE
OUT IS- DO WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
CENTER MANAGEMENT. DECEMBER
OKAY. RIGHT WHATEVER ONE FORM.
YEAH COPYRIGHT. I SAW THE. YEAH.
IF YOU WANT HAVE CONCERNS YEAH.
OKAY CENTERMAN WELCOME TO THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE REFER BILL ON
THIS COMMITTEE SO WELCOME- AND
THIS IS ITEM THREE SB THREE
NINETY ONE- CENTERMAN MAY FIRST
THANK YOU JERRY THANK YOU TO
THE CAN STAFF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB NINETY WHICH IS A
PERMISSIVE BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS- BOARDS TO SAFELY
MEET VIA TELECONFERENCES DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS- TO
ENSURE THAT PARTICIPATION. TO
THESE MEETINGS IS ACCESSIBLE TO
MEMBERS. THE DAVIS STERLING
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT
REQUIRES THE ID'S TO PROVIDE A
PHYSICAL MEETING LOCATION FOR
ALL TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS.
WHICH AS YOU CAN IMAGINE POSES
A SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISK IN
THE MIDST OF AN ONGOING
PANDEMIC. LAST YEAR IN RESPONSE
TO THIS CURRENT HEALTH CRISIS
THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER. ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS STATE AGENCIES TO
MEET AND VOTE REMOTELY. IT KNOW
SIMILAR ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN
FOR C. ID'S. CONSEQUENTLY
CITIES HAVE FACED IMMENSE
DIFFICULTIES IN ORGANIZING
LAWFUL MEETINGS IN THE MIST OF
THE ON GOING PANDEMIC. IN
RESPONSE TO THIS THE CALIFORNIA
LAW REVISION COMMITTEE WORK
LAST FALL TO CRAFT A NARROW
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS.
ASSEMBLY WAIVES THE REQUIREMENT
TO PROVIDE AN IN PERSON MEETING
LOCATION FOR TELECONFERENCE
MEETINGS DURING A DECLARED
EMERGENCY OR DISASTER. TO
STRATFORD THIS ENSURE THAT
PARTICIPATION IS ACCESSIBLE TO
MEMBERS THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
ID'S TO FULFILL THE FOLLOWING
REQUIREMENTS. THEY MUST PROVIDE
CLEAR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
PARTICIPATE. THE MEETING NOTICE
MUST INCLUDE THE TELEPHONE
NUMBER AND EMAIL THE PERSON WHO
CAN PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE PROCESS. BOTH
BEFORE AND DURING THE MEETING.
THEY MUST ENSURE THAT EVERY
DIRECTOR AND MEMBER HAS THE
SAME ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE MEETING THAT WOULD EXIST IF
THE MEETING WERE HELD IN PERSON.
ANY VOTER THE DIRECTOR SHALL BE
CONDUCTED BY A ROLL CALL VOTE.
AND LASTLY PARTICIPANTS MUST BE
GIVEN THE OPTION OF
PARTICIPATING BY TELEPHONE. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT OPPONENTS OF
THE BILLS HAVE HAD THIS BILL
HAVE RAISED SOME CONCERNS
REGARDING ADDITIONAL STEPS WE
CAN TAKE. TO ENSURE EASY ACCESS
TO PARTICIPATION AND SO AS A
RESULT WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT REQUIRES THE
ID'S TO PROVIDE INDIVIDUAL
NOTICE TO MEMBERS. OF THE FIRST
MEETING CONDUCTED DURING
EMERGENCY. THE AMENDMENT ALSO
REQUIRES C. ID'S TO REMIND
MEMBERS IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
NOTICE OF THEIR RIGHT TO OFTEN.
TO ALL MEETING NOTIFICATIONS. I
WANT TO BE CLEAR HOWEVER
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT GUARANTEE
FAIR AND SAFE PARTICIPATION OF
C. ID MEETINGS AS HAS BEEN SEEN
IN THE LAST YEAR. WE KNOW THAT
EMERGENCIES ARE GOING TO LIKELY
BE A PART OF OUR WAY OF LIFE-
WILDFIRES GLOBAL PANDEMICS
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF RECENT
EMERGENCIES THAT SHOW THAT IT'S
NOT ALWAYS POSSIBLE. OR SAFE
FORTY IDEAS TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON MEETING LOCATIONS-
THAT'S WHY SB THREE NINETY ONE
AGAIN A PERMISSIVE BILL THAT
SIMPLY GIVES THE ID'S AND
OPTION FOR MEETING DURING
OFFICIALLY DECLARED EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS. IS URGENTLY
NEEDED AND WE HAVE WITH US
TODAY- BRIAN HEY BEAR- OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVIEW
COMMISSION PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
AS WELL AS DIRECT PETROL A
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION'S
ATTORNEY FROM ORANGE COUNTY.
WHOSE FIRM PROVIDES LEAVE
COUNCILS FOR HUNDREDS OF SUCH
ASSOCIATIONS. TWENTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BYE CENTER IN TERMS
OF THE AMENDMENTS- I THINK WERE
ACCEPTING THEM RIGHT YES YEAH.
BUT MOST OF ALARM THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US SENATE OVER.
SOME OF OPPOSITION THAT MAYBE
DIDN'T THAT WE WERE WORKING AS
A MEMBERS WITH AND I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY SO-
EACH LEAD SUPPORTER AND SORT OF
PROPONENTS TO RECEIVE- TO MET-
TWO MINUTES IF THERE'S ONLY ONE
LEAD OPPONENT- WILL BE A LITTLE
MORE FLEXIBLE THERE SO THAT WE
HAVE- PARITY IN TIME. SORLEY'S
SUPPORTERS ARE I BELIEVE THIS
IS BRIAN HIBBARD AND DARK OUT
TOTAL- SO WE'LL START WITH-
BRIAN- HUBER. AND AGAIN YOU
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN GO ABOUT
GETTING YOUR MINISTRY TO OKAY
YES GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRIAN
HUBERT ON THE DIRECTOR OF THE
LAW REVISION COMMISSION BOB
QUINN- THE STATE'S FIRST HAD TO
STAY AT HOME ORDERS THE
COMMISSION WAS STRUGGLING A BIT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO HOLD OPEN
MEETINGS. BECAUSE THAT
APPLICABLE STATE OPEN MEETING
ACT REQUIRES THAT THERE BE A
PHYSICAL LOCATION PER
TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS- WE-
SOLVE THAT BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAIVING THAT REQUIREMENT BUT IT
MADE US AWARE OF THE FACT THAT-
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
WE'RE GONNA BE FACING THE SAME
PROBLEM AND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDERS WHAT HELPED
THEM- SO WE DECIDED TO QUICKLY.
DEVELOP AND TURN AROUND A
RECOMMENDATION WITH SIMILAR
FACT FOR COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT MEETINGS. IT WAS
INTENTIONALLY NARROW. THE ONLY
THAT IT. WHEN CAN PURCHASE
REQUIRE FOR TELECOM NEED AND
IDEA WELL WE ADDED. PROCEDURAL
ROUTE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE NAY
AFFECTED THE WAIVER WOULD NOT
UNDULY INTERFERE WITH MEMBERS
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
MEETINGS. AND FINALLY WE-
RECOMMENDED THAT IT BE AN
URGENCY MEASURE BECAUSE IN OUR
WORK WE LEARNED THAT MANY SEE
AIDID'S WE'RE GOING AT AND
HOLDING. MEETINGS IN KILEY BY
TELECONFERENCING VIOLATION OF
THE YOUNG PERSON REQUIREMENTS.
AND THAT CASTS A SORT OF A
CLOUD ON THE LEGITIMACY OF
ACTIONS TAKEN AT THOSE
MEETINGS. AND THE COMMISSION
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS URGENT TO
PUT A FIX IN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO LET'S SEE I CAN GET
BACK ON TO A CLEARLY LEGAL BUT
IT FOR THEIR MEETINGS- I'M
AVAILABLE. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW.
GO TO THE NEXT LEAD TO OUR
PROPONENT REGISTERED PETROL
HONEST APPROACH WE ALSO HAVE A
TWO MINUTE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
PHOTO ON THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY AND ARE FROM WORKING
IN TOUCH ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY
EXCLUSIVELY REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT TO SEE AIDID'S. WE
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF THEM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA JUST ABOUT
A YEAR AGO WITH THE VERY THE
VERY QUICK ONSET OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE SAW MANY
SEE AIDID'S FACED WITH VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES- THAT IS
ALREADY BEEN REFERENCE THE-
OPEN MEETING ACT FOR COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT EXPRESSLY
REQUIRES THE HOLDING OPEN OF A
PHYSICAL LOCATION FOR MEMBERS
TO ATTEND. HOWEVER VARIOUS
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS AND
MANDATES PREVENTED THOSE
GATHERINGS AND FURTHER EVEN IF
THEY TECHNICALLY DID NOT
VOLUNTEER BOARD MEMBERS
RESIDENTS IN PROFESSIONAL
MANAGEMENT THAT VERY SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT HOLDING SUCH
PHYSICAL LOCATION OPEN FOR
THOSE MEETINGS. SO AS SUCH AS A
VERY CREEK CRITICAL AND VERY
BUSY TIME IT BECAME REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR OUR VOLUNTEER
BOARDS TO DO THEIR JOB. AND
UNLIKE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THAT SAW THE BROWN ACT
SUSPENDED IN LIGHT OF ALL OF
THE THINGS TO GIVE THEM OTHER
OPTIONS THAT DID NOT OCCUR FOR
THE C. AIDID'S. SO AS SUCH BY
NECESSITY MANY COMMUNITIES
BEGAN OPENING CAN- CONDUCTING
OPEN MEETING. WITHOUT A
PHYSICAL LOCATION AND THE TREND
QUICKLY SPREAD ACROSS THE STATE
AND WHAT WE SAW IS THAT ENABLE
IN ATTENDANCE FROM. HOME BY
PHONE OR VIDEO SO EITHER
RESIDENTS ARE BOARD MEMBERS
NEED TO LEAVE THEIR HOME OR
FAMILY TO PARTICIPATE IS
PROTECTED RESIDENTS AND
COMMUNITY VOLUNTEERS FROM
EXPOSURE TO COLD NINETEEN WHICH
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN
OUR AGE RESTRICTED COMMUNITIES.
AND IN A LITTLE COMMITTEES TO
CONTINUE TO FUNCTION AT A
CRITICAL TIME WHEN FAMILIES
WERE STICKING CLOSE TO HOME
MORE THAN THEY EVER HAVE BEFORE
OR- SO IN THE END IT'S BEEN
OBSERVED BY EVERYBODY IN THE
INDUSTRY THAT THIS THAT THIS
TRANSITION DRAMATICALLY
INCREASED COMMUNITY MEMBER
INVOLVEMENT- AND WE'VE SEEN
MANY ASSOCIATIONS AND I JUST
WAS SPEAKING TO ONE TODAY AN
AGE RESTRICTED ASSOCIATION.
SAID LITERALLY THE
PARTICIPATION IN THEIR IN THEIR
MEETING HAS MORE. THAN DOUBLED
DURING THE LAST TWELVE SO OVER
THE REASONS I STRONG SAID. THE
OF A THREE ONE. WHICH OKADA
THIS PRACTICE I TRULY BELIEVE
IT'S NOT THE- IN BETTER. FOR
ALL CAN SO. AND IMPORTANTLY
EVERY. AND THE OWNER AND- READ
WITHIN HIM. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE WE WILL BUT ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO
SUPPORT OF. PUBLIC COMMENT IN
PERSON- IN FOR TWO OR THREE.
SALAS CELL. SEEING NINE ARE
WILL NOW LOOK AT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. C. NG NINE CALLING OVER
THE PHONE LINES NOW WE ARE
GOING TO- HI INSTEAD OF DOING
FIFTEEN CALLERS FOR CYBER GONNA
ACTUALLY MAKE IT EQUAL TIME.
PROPER SIDE OF THE FIFTEEN
MINUTES PER SIDE- IN THE ARMY
TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. AND SO
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ARE NOT A MODERATOR TO
KEEP PEOPLE OUT. HI IN SUPPORT
OF- FIVE S. B. THREE NINETY
ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE FOR IN Q. OR
TRYING NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE MEMBERS JENNIFER
SPECTRUM HAPPY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF
MINE ONE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN CALLING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT.
HOWEVER TRYING TO ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. JENNIFER
WATER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY MANAGER WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND FRAN WE
NEED YOU NEED TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENT THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR. THE BILL MAHER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M MORE
TRYING TO FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ROBERT NICKEL ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTING ACTION
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW GO TO- OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE NINETY ONE. WE DO HAVE
ONE THIS IS A PARTNER WHO IS
WITH US HERE TODAY AND THAT IS
MARJORIE MURRAY FROM THE CENTER
FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS.
ASSOCIATION LAW- AND SO- IS
VERY BECAUSE THE OPPOSITION HAD
THE TOTAL PERFORMANCE WILL
GRANT WILL BE USED WILL HAVE
FOUR MINUTES SINCE ARE NORTH OF
THE- WITNESSES SO. YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AYE MARJORIE MURRAY.
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATION LAW WE ARE A
NONPROFIT. WHOSE MISSION IS TO
PROTECT THE CONSUMER AND CIVIL
RIGHTS OF ASSOCIATION
HOMEOWNERS. WOULD HAVE TAKEN
OPPOSE POSITION NOT BECAUSE
WE'RE AGAINST THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY. O CONVENE
ASSOCIATION MEETINGS DURING AN
EMERGENCY BUT RATHER WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT ITS USE DOES NOT
INFRINGE ON. EXISTING RIGHTS OF
ASSOCIATION HOMEOWNERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR OWN
GOVERNANCE. WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED. THE TECHNOLOGY. NOT
DELETE THOSE RIGHT. THE LARGEST
ITSELF HAS TO CARE DURING THE-
STATEWIDE PANDEMIC. TO ENSURE
THAT VOTERS CAN STILL
PARTICIPATE IN GOVERNANCE LIKE
THIS HEARING FOR EXAMPLE.
LIKEWISE WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THE RIGHT TO HOMEOWNERS IN SELF
GOVERNMENT COMMUNITIES ARE ALSO
PROTECTED DURING EMERGENCIES.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
STEPS TO RESOLVE OUR VERY FIRST
CONCERN ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
NOTIFYING HOMEOWNERS. OF
MEETINGS DURING THE EMERGENCY.
THAT IS PROVIDING INDIVIDUAL
NOTICE TO THE HOMEOWNER THAT A
MEETING IS ON THE HORIZON.
HOWEVER WE REMAIN CONCERNED
ABOUT OTHER ISSUES WHICHARE
ITEMIZED IN THE ANALYSIS FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE MEETING BE
RECORDED FOR THE BENEFIT OF
ABSENT HOMEOWNERS AND BOARD
DIRECTORS A LIGHT. IF WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AN EMERGENCY
HOMEOWNERS AND BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ARE ENGAGED IN.
TRYING TO RESOLVE INSURANCE
ISSUES THEY'RE STANDING IN LINE
AT THE FOOD BANK. THERE ARE
HOME SCHOOLING THEIR CHILDREN
THEY'RE SEARCHING FOR WORK THEY
MAY NOT HAVE TIME TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ASSOCIATION
BOARD MEETING. SECOND THERE IS
THE ISSUE OF THE LEADING THE
PHYSICAL LOCATION REQUIREMENTS
WELL WE CAN UNDERSTAND THAT
FROM. A HEALTH POINTOF VIEW
PERHAPS IT INFRINGES ON
ACTUALLY DELETES AN EXISTING
RIGHT TO HOMEOWNERS TO BE ABLE
TO WITNESS THE TABULATION AND
MANAGEMENT. OF VOTING MATERIALS
DURING AN ELECTION THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL VOTER RIGHT. SO WHILE
WE RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
ELECTRONIC MEETINGS DURING AN
EMERGENCY WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
IT NOT INFRINGING ON OR DELETE
EXISTING RIGHTS. UP SINCE THE
AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND IS WORKING
TOWARDS RESOLVING THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO TAKING UP THE OTHER
ISSUES OF CONCERN. WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF
HOPEFULLY TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OKAY WE WILL NOW GO TO ANY
OTHER IN PERSON ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE OPPOSITION PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAIN FOR GOING FORWARD
WE ASKED FOLKS TO PLEASE THE
RIGHT OR YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IF ANY AND THE FACT THAT YOU
OPPOSE BUT- MY NAME IS TOM SIR
I'M A RETIRED THIS RECORD
COMMISSIONER I AM ON THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE OF THE
CENTER THAT MARJORIE MURRAY IS
A PRESENT ENOUGH. AND I'M HERE
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF RETIRED
AMERICANS IF THERE'S ANY TIME
LEFT FOR THE LEAD I HAD TO HAVE
SOME FOR THEIR STATEMENTS YES I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD OR WAS ABOUT
FORTY FIVE SECONDS LEFT SO
WE'RE ANTICIPATING SECOND LEAD
WITNESS ON BEHALF OF THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY MIGHT BE
CALLING IN. BUT I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT'S HOW IT YES SO YOU. HAVE
THEM BOB YOU HAVE. YOU HAVE
FORTY SO. WHICH ALL START NOW
AND ALL RIGHT I'D LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE- HAVING A LIVE MEETING
WHERE THERE'S COUNTING OF
BALLOTS TAKES PLACE. NOTING
THAT IN THE RECENT FEDERAL
ELECTION. OF THE SCORES OF
LAWSUITS FILED BY A FORMER
PRESIDENT CHALLENGING. THE
ELECTION THE OLD ONE CASE THAT
PREVAILED ON BEHALF OF OUR
FORMER PRESIDENT. HAD TO DO
WITH IT WITNESSING OF COUNTING
OF BALLOTS. IT'S AN ESSENTIAL
PART. OF THE EXERCISE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC ELECTION THAT THAT
PROVIDES THE- HUH SURE INSTEAD
IT THE ELECTIONS CONDUCTED
FAIRLY AND THAT THE- PUBLIC CAN
BE CONFIDENT THAT THE ELECTION
RESULTS ARE CORRECT SO IF WE
DON'T HAVE. ACTUAL IN PERSON
WITNESSING OF THE COUNTING OF
THE BALLOTS IT LEAVES THE GATE
WIDE OPEN FOR SHENANIGANS WITH
ELECTIONS WHICH WE HAVE HEARD
MANY MANY CASES. FROM ALL
AROUND THE STATE THAT INCUMBENT
BOARDS IN OFFICERS WILL DO
ANYTHING TO REMAIN IN OFFICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INPUT. OKAY IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THING NINE IS THERE ANY
ONE IN OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY
FORTY.SEVEN NINE WILL NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINES AND AGAIN
FOR EVERYONE WAITING TO THIS IS
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. TO SB
THREE NINETY ONE. FOR EACH
PERSON WE WILL ASK YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY
AND THE FACT THAT YOU OPPOSE-
BUT OF OPERATOR CAN YOU ASK
PEOPLE TO QUEUE UP AND THEN LET
ME KNOW HOW MANY OPPOSITION
SPEAKERS THERE ARE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINETY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
OUT DESCRIBING. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY AND COULD YOU
JUST MAKE ONE MORE CALL FOR THE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
WALDRON YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF AN OPERATOR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- SENATOR- CABALLERO
WOMEN'S CENTER MIKE POUNCEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR- THERE WERE SEVERAL-
SUGGESTIONS THAT ARE ARE IN
THE- IN THE ANALYSIS AND IT FOR
CHANGE AND- WHAT I IT SOUNDS TO
ME LIKE THERE WAS ONLY ONE. OF
THE SUGGESTIONS THAT YOU TOOK
SENATOR MAN I SAID ON JUDICIARY
IF THIS GETS OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE IT'S GOING TO MOVE ON
TO JUDICIARY- BUT I JUST WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR THAT- THAT I
AGREE WITH WITH SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED-
I THINK THAT IT M. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW
C. ID'S TO HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE.
BOB WHEN THERE IS AN EMERGENCY
SO I GRANT YOU THAT- SO TO
WAIVE THE IN PERSON
REQUIREMENTS IS GOOD BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT-
EVERY INDIVIDUAL THAT ARE PART
OF THE C. ID RECEIVE SOME KIND
OF NOTICE THAT DIDN'T THE
MEETING IS NOT GOING TO BE HELD
IN PERSON WHETHER THAT'S-
THROUGH A TEXT OR AN EMAIL OR
AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF WAYS
TO. TO BE ABLE TO EFFECTUATE IN
INDIVIDUAL DELIVERY NOW THAT
DOESN'T REQUIRE YOU SEND THAT
LETTER THROUGH THE MAIL- I
THINK THERE HOULD BE A
PHYSICAL LOCATION FOR BALLOT
COUNTING- OF COURSE SOME WAY
THAT YOU CAN ACCESS THE
INFORMATION IF THAT IF THERE'S
NOT A PHYSICAL LOCATION THE
BALLOTS ARE KEPT AND SOMEBODY
CAN LOOK AT A MAP AFTER THE
FACT IF THEY WANT TO. I THINK
THE RETURN MEETING SHOULD BE
RECORDED EVERYTHING GETS
RECORDED NOW AND- MOST OF THAT
PUBLIC PLATFORMS YOU CAN USE-
ALLOW YOU TO RECORD IT SO THAT
IF I'M BUSY WHEN THE MEETINGS
BEING HELD AND I WANT TO SEE IT
THE NEXT MORNING OR SOMETHING
THAT I HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
AND I DO THINK THERE SHOULD BE
SOME ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IF
THE RULES ARE VIOLATED THERE
SHOULD BE A WAY FOR ONE OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE- C. ID TO FILE A
COMPLAINT OR A CHALLENGE AND
THAT IT BE HEARD SOMEWHERE SO-
WHETHER IT'S THAT BROWN ACT-
ABABNEH PROCESSOR OR SOMETHING
ELSE I'M NEUTRAL ON THAT BUT I
DO. THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE
SOME KIND OF REMEDY. SHE OF
HAVING TO GO COURT LEAST. BUT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I'M
PREPARED TO MOVE THE BILL IF
THAT'S APPROPRIATE OKAY SO THAT
IS A- BUT MOTION. TO DISMISS.
THE PATH AS AMENDED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMANDED A SHORT
BREATH- CENTER ACCOUNTS. I TO
SIT ON JUDICIARY SELFIE SEEN
THIS AGAIN BUT- I WAS THE
AUTHOR OF THE H. AWAY CHANGES
THAT REQUIRE PHYSICAL PRESENCE
AND FOR COUNTING OF BALLOTS
THAT THERE WAS. A LOT OF PAIN
AND SUFFERING THAT WENT THROUGH
GETTING THOSE CHANGES TO THE H.
AWAY SO I GUESS I'D LIKE TO SEE
HERE RESPOND TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RURAL SALINAS- WHAT YOU'RE-
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING ON THE
BILL- IT'S BECAUSE- BEEN. COME
UP AND THE ALLEGE IT'S SUCH AN
INTEGRAL OF THE CHANGES THAT WE
HAVE ON THE OPERATIONS OF A
CHOICE. HI MISTER CHAIR DO I
HAVE PERMISSION TO RESPOND
DRIVE JUST CRIED- SO THIS IS
SOMETHING I'M HAPPY TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES WHEN HERE'S WELL BUT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS.
CONSIDERED AND I WAS RAISED IN
MEETINGS WITH A LOT OF YOU
COMMISSION BUT- I THINK
ULTIMATELY THERE WERE CONCERNS
ON THE FLIP SIDE WHICH IS IN A
IN A CURRENT PANDEMIC. FOURTEEN
A WILDFIRE A PHYSICAL LOCATION
ACTUALLY WOULD EXCLUDE A LOT OF
PEOPLE FROM PARTICIPATING.
BECAUSE THERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
FOLKS RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
RELUCTANT TO COME TO IN PERSON
BOKE TABULATIONS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT. OR OR MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO DURING CERTAIN TYPES OF
EMERGENCIES RIGHT AND AGAIN
THIS IS A PERMISSIVE MEASURE.
THAT ONLY APPLIES WHEN THERE'S
AN OFFICIAL THE CARD MERGING
SEA- AND SO I THINK THE THOUGHT
WAS THAT A TELECOM VIDEO
CONFERENCE. WHERE THE VOTES
WERE ACTUALLY SEEN OVER CAMERAS
WOULDBE. MORE PARTICIPATORY
THEN IN IN PERSON UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SO THAT WAS
THE THINKING BEHIND IT- AND SO
YOU KNOW IS JUST KIND OF A
TRADE OFF THING BUT OF COURSE I
HIGH VALUE. YOU KNOW I I'VE YOU
HOAS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT FORM
OF DEMOCRACY AND WE ARE NOT IN
THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO TRY TO.
DISENFRANCHISE ANYONE OR TAKE
AWAY AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF
PARTICIPATORY DEMOCRACY SO
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK THROUGH
THESE CONCERNS I THINK. I'M
WALKING YOU THROUGH THE
REASONING THAT WE HAD AND I
DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE. TO HAVE
OUR WITNESSES RESPOND AS WELL.
WHICH ONE. I THINK IT WOULD BE
THE LARA MISTER HAGER FIRST.
OKAY YES SHARKS SURE I CAN
SPEAK TO THE COMMISSION'S
THINKING ON THOSE- WHEN WE'RE
DEVELOPING OUR PROPOSAL THE
ISSUE WAS RAISED BY MISTER AT
THAT TIME. WHEN WE DID DISCUSS
IT AND IT WAS SENT TO THE
COMMISSION THE MATH THAT THAT
SENATOR MAN DESCRIBES. COUNTING
THE BALLOTS IN FRONT THE
CAMERAS WHATEVER CAN SEE.
WHAT'S ON THE PAPER AS IT'S
BEING READ BY THE INSPECTOR.
WOULD BE SUFFICIENT TO. THE
TERM FRAUDULENT- WHICH WE GUESS
BECAUSE THE PURPOSE OF THAT
REQUIREMENT- I UNDERSTOOD COULD
SUBSEQUENT CONVERSATIONS WITH
MISSIONARY BUT SHE'S WORRIED
THAT SOME PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO SEE THE BALLOT EVEN ON
A CAMERA BECAUSE THEY'RE-
PARTICIPATING BY TELEPHONE AND
I. UNDERSTAND THAT AND- THE
JUDGMENT CALL THAT POINT THE
COMMISSION WAS FOCUSED ON
KEEPING THE BILL'S VERY NARROW.
TICKETS ARE BECAUSE WE WERE
HOPING TO HAVE THE PASS ON
EMERGENCY BILLS ITSELF. WE
WEREN'T PERSUADED AT THAT POINT
THAT MORE WAS NEEDED THAT.
EXCEPT TO THE LEGISLATURE TO
THE SIDE. FRESHEN UP YEAH I
THINK THE I THINK THIS OF.
MISTER CHAIR I AM AND IT'S ODD
HOW THE PANDEMIC IS WORKING
ISN'T WHAT WE THINK WORK WHAT
MY THINKING WAS IN OCTOBER IS
DIFFERENT TO MY THINKING AND IN
MARCH SO. I'M GOING TO JUST
STAY OFF THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE
I GET A CHANCE TO SEE IT AGAIN
AND- AS IN TO DISH JERRY IN
FULL. I WANT TO SCREW UP A
LITTLE BIT. AND WE'D BE HAPPY
INTERACT WITH YOUR STAFF. IS
THERE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
COUNCIL TO SPEAK. NOW I THINK
WERE I THINK WE'RE OKAY- SO-
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES. OKAY WE DO A
MOTION- TO PASS TO JUDICIARY AS
AMENDED I'M RECOMMENDING AN AYE
VOTE. ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK CENTERMAN FOR WORKING
WITH OUR COMMITTEE AND FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH US
STAKEHOLDERS SO. WE DO HAVE THE
MOTION AND WE WILL CALL A NINE
I'M SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE WITH YES I JUST WANTED TO
BRIEFLY ADDRESS THE RECORDING
ISSUE- MY STAFF IS RAISED TO MY
ATTENTION THAT THIS WOULD
REQUIRE A CHANGE OF THE LAW.
BECAUSE HOAS RIGHT NOW ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO RECORD THEIR
MEETING SO I THINK THE GOAL
HERE WAS AGAIN- AS A MYSTERY
THERE SAID TO KEEP THIS NARROW
SINCE IT'S AN URGENCY MEASURES
SO WE DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE
MASSIVE CHANGES TO LAW HERE-
AND SO THAT WAS OUR REASONING
BEHIND NOT REQUIRING RECORDINGS
AND AGAIN THIS IS MEANT TO JUST
APPLYING A VERY NARROW SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES SUCH AS TODAY.
WHEN H. AWAY CAN'T HAVE NAME
EIGHT IT WORKS DIFFICULT OR
PROBLEMATIC FOR NATURE WAY TO
HAVE AN IN PERSON MEETING UP
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- YOU KNOW THE CURRENT
CRISIS THE PANDEMIC IS
ILLUSTRATED THE NEED TO HAVE
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF MEETING-
THIS IS APPLIED TO THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF COURSE BUT- HOAS
ARE AN IMPORTANT FORM. OF
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AND. AND I
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO GIVE
THEM SOME. LIMITED ABILITY FIND
OUT. TO IN PERSON MEETINGS.
CIRCUMSTANCES WARRANT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU AND I'LL
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SB THREE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR MA'AM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR WIENER. AYE WIENER AYE
BATES. BATES NOT BURNING
CABALLERO. CABALLERO HI CORTESE
AYE PARTISI AYE MCGUIRE BUT
CHAU BULK HI THE TROUBLE I
SKINNER HI SKINNER I AM BURKE
WHAT KASKY NOBODY ELSE CAN
OPERATE. FIVE OKAY BUT- HAS
ENOUGH VOTES TO GET UP WE'RE
GONNA PUT HER ON CALL FOR-
ABSENT MEMBER SO- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR MEMBERS. OKAY
WE'LL NEXT GO TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR SB TWO NINETY. FIVE
SENATORS SKINNER. ONE OF OUR.
WHENEVER AUGUST THIRTY FIRST
MIDNIGHT BILLS. RIGHT YEAH.
REPORT DURING. FOR THE RECORD
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
SO R. S. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE AS
THE CHAIR JUST REFERENCED WAS A
BILL THAT SUCCESSFULLY GOT IT
ALMOST TO THE FINISH LINE LAST
YEAR AND IT WAS- PASSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY. BUT CONCURRENCE WITH
SIXTY WELL NOT CONCURRENCE
BECAUSE THEY NEED TO COME TO
CENTER FOR THAT BUT WE SIXTY
SEVEN FIVE VOTES IT WAS ON ITS
WAY TO THE SENATE WHEN WE HIT
OUR MIDNIGHT DEADLINE- SO I AM
HOPEFUL THAT. WE CAN- THIS YEAR
PASS THIS BILL AND WHAT SB TWO
NINETY DOES. IS IT ADDRESSES
CALIFORNIA'S DENSITY BONUS LAW
AND MAKE SOME IMPROVEMENTS TO
IT OUR DENSITY BONUS LAW IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TOOL TO
INCENTIVIZE THE BUILDING OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS WITHIN
MARKET RATE. STRUCTURES MARKET
RATE PROJECTS. NOW
INTERESTINGLY WITH SUCH AN
IMPORTANT GOOD BILL LIKE THE
DENSITY BONUS BILL YOU'D BE
SURPRISED TO KNOW THAT LESS
THAN HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THUS FAR
APPROVED THE PROJECT. THAT IS
TAKEN IT OF THE DENSITY BONUS
BUILT IN SINCE ALMOST ALL
HOUSING IN THE STATE IS IN
FACT. IN OUR- PAID FOR BY
PRIVATE SECTOR DEVELOPERS IF
THEY'RE NOT UTILIZING SUCH A
TOOL IS THIS IN A FAR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE NOT UTILIZING
SUCH A TOOL IS THIS THEN WE ARE
BUILDING LESS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND WE NEED TO BUILD
ALL HOUSING BUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADDITIONALLY. THE GOAL
OF S. B. TWO NINETY IS TO
CLARIFY AND IMPROVE OUR DENSITY
BONUS LAW SO THAT ACTUALLY
INCREASES OR RESULTS IN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS THAT
ARE BUILT IN OUR STATE AND
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THESE MARKET
RATE PROJECTS. TO IMPROVE THE
ABILITY FOR FIVE FOUR RATHER
DESSERTS PROVISIONS IT CONFORMS
THE DENSITY BONUS APPROVAL
WHICH REQUIREMENTS IN OUR
EXISTING HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT IT EXPANDS THE DEFINITION
OF FOR SALE PROJECTS BEYOND
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS SO
IT INCLUDES THE IT UNITS FOR
LOW INCOME FAMILIES. IT ADDS A
PARKING WAIVER FOR SALE
PROJECTS THAT ARE WITHIN A HALF
A MILE OF TRANSIT IN INCLUDE
40% OF MODERATE INCOME UNITS.
AND IT. IMPROVE THE ABILITY OF
THE DENSITY BONUS TO BE USED
FOR STUDENT HOUSING WHICH IT
CURRENTLY IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
USE IT BECAUSE STUDENT HOUSING.
IS ARE. USUALLY DESIGNED. NOT
AS A IF YOU THINK ABOUT LIKE
DORMITORY STYLE HOUSING WHEN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUILD
STUDENT HOUSING THEY MAY PUT A
NUMBER OF QUOTE UNQUOTE UNITS
ON THE FLOOR BUT ONLY ONE
KITCHEN. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
THESE ADJUSTMENTS BECAUSE THE
WAY OUR USUAL CONFIGURATIONS
ARE SUCH THAT A UNIT MUST BE
YOU KNOW X. NUMBER OF OOMS IN
THE KITCHEN AND NOT IN A
DORMITORY STYLE- CONFIGURATION
SO WHAT THIS WOULD DO IS
ENABLE. A DEVELOPER TO GET UP
TO ONE INCENTIVE FOR UNDER THE
DENSITY BONUS BILL IF 20% OF
THE UNITS ARE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WITHIN A STUDENT
HOUSING CONFIGURED TYPE
PROJECT- SO THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL DOES AND I HAVE- TWO
EXCELLENT WITNESSES. DAVID
GARCIA FROM UC BERKELEY
STANDARD TURNER CENTER AND
PATRICK KENNEDY OF PANORAMIC
INTERESTS AND- YOU COULD TURN
TO THE WITNESSES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- SO EACH LEAD WITNESS
WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES- ANSWER
WILL START WITH- PATRICK
KENNEDY MR COMING. CAN YOU HEAR
ME RETURN. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU- SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER- MY NAME'S
PATRICK KENNEDY HAVE BEEN
DEVELOPING IN THE BAY AREA
SINCE- NINETEEN NINETY AND- I
WAS THE FIRST- DEVELOPED ACCUSE
THE DENSITY BONUS IN BERKELEY
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT- THEN
IN THE SPACE OF ABOUT. SEVEN
YEARS I BUILT CLOSE TO FIVE
HUNDRED APARTMENTS OF WHICH
ALMOST A HUNDRED WERE SET ASIDE.
FOR LOW INCOME. AS A RESULT OF
THE DENSITY BONUS PROVISIONS
AND TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW THE BUILDING THOSE A
HUNDRED OR SO UNITS- WE BECAME
A LARGER A LANDLORD OF LOW
INCOME APARTMENTS IN THE CITY
OF BERKELEY HOUSING AUTHORITY
AND WITH NO COST TO THE CITY.
AND ALL THE UNITS STATE ON THE
TAX ROLLS OF THE DENSITY BONUS
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE
WAY TO GET PRIVATE DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD. LOW INCOME HOUSING-
I'VE ALSO USED THE HOURS ALSO-
THE FIRST BALLOT PRETTY USING
DENSITY BALLOTS AND SAN
FRANCISCO. BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND SINCE THEN I THINK
ANOTHER THOUSAND OR MORE
PROJECTS HAVE UTILIZED THAT SO
IT'S AN EFFECTIVE INCENTIVE.
THAT THAT- I THINK SHOULD BE
ENHANCED IN WHATEVER WAY IT CAN
ONE THING I'VE LEARNED WHEN I
WAS IN BERKELEY. THIS IS THAT
OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS OF
WHICH THERE ARE MANY NOW-
CANNOT AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THE
LOW INCOME UNITS PROVIDED BY
THE DENSITY BONUS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO PROVISION TO ALLOW
STUDENTS. TO RENT AN APARTMENT-
IN A IN A BUILDING THAT HAVE
BENEFITTED BONUS LOW INCOME
UNITS AND I THINK- SENATORS
SCANNERS- LEGISLATION TODAY
WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
IN CHANGING THAT. AND ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THE POTENTIAL TO BE IN
SUBSIDIZED BELOW MARKET RATE
UNITS. THAT ARE BUILT BY
DEVELOPERS LIKE MYSELF- USING
THE DENSITY BONUS SO- I'D LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO- ADOPT
SPENDER SKATERS THAT
LEGISLATION PERSONALLY I'D LIKE
TO SEE MORE THAN ONE INCENTIVE
MAYBE TWO INCENTIVES ARE
TREATED BUT NOW WE THANK YOU-
I'M HAPPY TO WAIT. FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION OF THE FOR THE
PRINTER REVISIONS TO IT- AND
I'D LIKE TO HER G. JIM. TO
APPROVE IT I'M THANK YOU MISTER
KENNEDY THANK YOU- ONE ALGA
DAVID. FROM THE TURNER CENTER
ON THROUGH. TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU ENDED UP J. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS COURSE. IF
YOU DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION
HOUSING. THAT YOU KEEP WE ARE
HOW RESEARCH AND CALL ORGANS
THAT. AT BERKELEY FOCUSING ON
ALL MATTERS OF HOUSING ISSUE
FROM PLAN YOU JUNE COSTS
BUILDING HAS. UP FROM EIGHTY
INSTEAD OF COMING HOME TO
MARKET LIKE A- BUT TODAY AND TO
TESTIFY SUPPORT OF TO NINE FROM
SAN SKINNER. THE IN PRINCIPLE
THERE WERE. HAS SHOWN THAT THE
DENSITY BY LAW THAT SHOULD BE
REFORM. TO ENCOURAGE YOU
GREATER. SPECIFICALLY ARE CAL
RESIDENTIAL LAND SURVEY WHICH
WAS OF PLANNING TO STRUCK THE
STATE. ON THE FROM TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO SEVEN. MORE THAN OF
YOUR- THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
REPORTED TO US TODAY HAD NO
DENSITY BONUS YOU WHAT. AND
EVEN IN THE CITY THAT IT. THEY
HAD BEEN GOING TO SEE. MOST OF
US ARE REPORT ONLY HAVE ONE. OR
TWO DID YOU PARKED DURING THAT.
THREE YEAR PERIOD. SO IT'S
CLEAR THAT CHANGES THE DESK
BONUS LAW. ARE NEEDED TO REALLY
INCREASE. IT USAGE AND TO DRAWNOT TO. ONE HUNDRED OVERALL
THAT ALSO SURE TO. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE
COURT NINETY TAKES IMPORTANT.
TARGETED STEPS TO IMPROVE THE
EAGLES OF THE UNITED. BY X. LAW
HOMEOWNERS IS STUDENT HOUSING
GROUP. WHICH ARE AS YOU KNOW
CRITICALLY IN NEED. THESE ARE
SIMPLE. TRICK PART OF THAT
COULD HELP IN MODEL TOWARD
USING THE UNITED. MORE PROJECTS
THE STATE WHICH IS WHY WAS A
PART OF THE CHANGE PROPOSED IN
THIS. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE AND SENATORS FORGET
WORKING ISSUE AND FOR THE- TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF BURBANK NOW
SO THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU
MISTER. WE'LL MEXICO. TO- FIVE
THE GENERAL PUBLIC. WHICH AGAIN
IS FOR A- GOING FORWARD.
LIMITED TO YOUR NAME YOUR- IF
ANY. AND THE FIVE THAT USE OF
LISTA IN FORTY OR THREE. GO
AHEAD I'M CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TOWARD A STRAT THREE SO M. B.
OF THE- ACTION CALL. FOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DON'T SEE ANYONEIN
TWO OH THREE. SO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOUR AND IS. SEEING WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OUT OF
ALL CAN YOU PLEASE UP SOME. FOR
S. B- TWO NINETY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO NINETY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE LET ME KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE CUTE ON. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN THE QUEUE
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
GO WE'RE GONNA WILL HAVE A
FIFTEEN MINUTE. LIMIT THAT
SHOULD BE PLENTY FOR TWENTY- OF
THESE. SO AGAIN CHESTER NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT- YOU CAN
GO AHEAD NOT AN OPERATOR. THANK
YOU ARE LYING TO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATHY
BENELUX AND REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ADAM
REGULATE THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THE PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO FORTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD- SECURE A
BOB TAYLOR REPRESENTING FIELD
CERTAIN COMPANY AND AN ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF HOUSING EXPANSION
STRUGGLING UPPORT OF S. P. TO
NINETY. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CALLING FOR MANY NEGATIVES OF
LIFE HEALTH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
BURKE CALIFORNIA YIMBY THE
COUNCIL OF INTEL BUILDERS SB AT
HOME CAN HELP PROPERTIES AND
TMG PARTNERS ALL IN SUPPORT OF
THAT BEAT. TO NINETY. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT TO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GIVE ME PAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN THE COURT THANK YOU.
BLIND ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AREN'T ABLE AND FAIR
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ALFRED TO
THE AMERICAN IN IN BERKELEY AND
I'M IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALLOWED ONE NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO BE MORE
SONIC LOS ANGELES WITH ABUNDANT
HOUSING LA ONE SEPTEMBRIE ONE
REPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY
DON'T ONE SIX FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GLOBAL WOULD BE I DON'T
KNOW. ONE WELL THAT'S ABOUT THE
IT THE- BEFORE YEAH. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO FIFTY PLEASED
AHEAD. I AM ARE ARE FROM EAST
BAY PROUD IN OF THE BILL. THANK
ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY SIX GO OUT.
KEVIN ANDERSON BEHALF OF
SILICON COMMUNITY AND IN THE-
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO SET SIX
PLEASE CALL. REMEMBER MICHAEL
WITH THE BUILDING AND IS. IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A LITTLE
NIGHT HE'S FROM THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. I THANK
YOU RYAN TO FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I HAVE A DIFFICULTY
BEING WITH IN THE ACTION AND
CONFLICT FOR EVERYONE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M TO
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ROBERT BURTON FROM SAN
FRANCISCO MEMBERS. THE
COMMUNITY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I'M TO TANK PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JORDAN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE GOING TO FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT ON
BEHALF OF THE IN THE ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M
TWO EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BERMAN TOLD ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY CRUZ THE ASSEMBLY
BACKYARD OR- THANK YOU OF MY
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS ALSO
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STEPHEN BUS WRITTEN IN THE LAW
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
CAN DOLLARS SENTENCES COULD
BILLION CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL POSING AS. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU- WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION- WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD OPPONENTS
IDENTIFIED AS OR ANYONE FORTY
TWO A THREE OPPOSING. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSING. THING
NINE ONE I'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES BOTTOM OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP OPPONENTS TO SB.
TWO NINETY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWO NINETY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
LET ME KNOW HOW MANY ARE QUEUED
UP. I THANK YOU WE CURRENTLY
HAVE STRIVE IN Q. HELLO I. ONE
THIRTY. AT NINE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD ELLERY
HARNESS ASSOCIATION WITH FAVOR
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS
UNLIVABLE CALIFORNIAN UNITED.
THANK YOU ONE NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AS FAR. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE NINETY. RIGHT HANDER OUT OF
BODY OF LAFAYETTE AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA LINE
OF LOCAL ELECTIONS AND I. L.
THANK YOU I'M TO SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EMILY GABEL
LUDDY PATH MAYOR BURBANK I'VE
BEEN THROUGH SEVERAL DENSITY
BONUSES AND THEY DO WORK SO I'M
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX
OR SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M DAVID WHEATLEY MEMBER OF
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
CITIES FOR LOCAL CONTROL
INDIVIDUALLY THE URBAN DESIGN
AND PRESERVATION COMMITTEE
THAT'S OVER LAKE NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU I AM TO SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LITTLE RIVERSIDE AND
MORENO VALLEY WE NEED TO HAVE
ACQUIRED AFFORDABILITY YOUR
REQUIREMENTS WE OPPOSE. THANK
YOU I'M TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES I- VIRGINIA MCISAAC
SAN MATTEO CALIFORNIA- I
BELIEVE WE NEED TO HAVE A
HIGHER AFFORDABILITY INCLUDED
IN THE IN THE IT ALSO I DON'T
KNOW. I REMEMBER HOW MANY MORE
LINED UP YOU SAID FIVE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS CURIOUS. I
CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE MORE IN Q.
OKAY CURRENT. THANK YOU OF MINE
TO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
MY NAME IS AMY GALA DAY I
REPRESENT BEVERLY WILSHIRE
HOMEOWNERS AND GREATER FAIRFAX
RESIDENT ASSOCIATION AND THERE
IS NO CRISIS HERE BECAUSE
BUILDINGS HAVE BEEN TORN DOWN
THE PEOPLE WERE LIVING IN TO
PUT UP LUXURY APARTMENTS AND IF
THAT IS THE SOLUTION TO TEAR
DOWN- AFFORDABLE RENT
CONTROLLED APARTMENTS TO PUT UP.
THREE APARTMENTS THAT ARE HALF
EMPTY. A USING THAT. EVERYONE
THANK YOU WE NOW INTEL. THANK
YOU I'M TWO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE GREAT NORTHERN
WITH CATALYST NO I OPPOSE.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE NIGHT SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE NINE
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY DON'T
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHITE WINE
IS FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLAME
TO NINETY THREE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS CHRISTY RODNEY ON
THE OF BURKE VALLEY
NEIGHBORHOODS WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU I'M TWO OR THREE GO
OUT. I ASSEMBLY TESTER
CALIFORNIA LINE BUT LOCAL
ELECTED SUPPOSED. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ONE OPERATOR- WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER MICHALSKI I KNOW YOU'RE
SAYING NO. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SAYING NINE- I
AM RECOMMENDING AND AYE VOTES
ON- THIS- THIS BILL IT WAS A-
SIDE TO SAY THE LEAST THAT THIS
BILL DIED BECAUSE THE CLOCK
STRUCK MIDNIGHT ON AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST- AND SO I WANT TO
THANK. HER FOR PERSEVERING AND
I'M BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. BACKED SO WITH THAT I AM
RECOMMENDING AND I'D GO TO A
MOTION TO- HOUSES AND REFERRED
TO THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE CENTER ACCOUNTS HE IS
MOVING- AND SO YOU MAKE. THANK
YOU CHAIR YES POLICE- HELP TURN
A SUCCESSFUL BILL THAT TURNED
INTO A PUMPKIN BACK INTO A-
INTO THE- THE BILL THAT- WILLS
WILL ADDRESS OUR IMPORTANT
HOUSING NEEDS WITHOUT AYE AS
FOR YOUR TYPE OF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WITHOUT WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL
TO NINETY BY SENATOR SKINNER
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WINNER. WINNER
I'D BATES BATES NOW CABALLERO
HI. HI CORTESE I'VE CORTESE I
MCGUIRE. A CHARGEABLE. OCTOBER
NOT BURDEN. FOR TROUBLED UPPER
SKI FIVE SKINNER ARE NUMBER
LOCALES DE CASKEY AVE. BY BOAT.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES WILL
FIFTY WILL IT ON CALL AND- WILL
NOW GO TO ITEM FIVE AND PER
ITEM FIVE AND SIX WHICH I'LL BE
PRESENTING GONNA HAVE TO GO
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR
BATES. NUMBER WIRE NUMBER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF- THE- RIGHT.
ARE YOU GOING TO STAY THERE
YEAH. THEN WILL COME OUT
SENATOR WIENER YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL FIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- VETERANS BY SIR OUR
COLLEAGUES. SB TIME IT. IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF LAST YEAR'S
SENATE BILL NINE OH TWO WHICH
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED THANK YOU
ONE OF THE SENATE PASSED. THE
BILL HAS AGAIN FOR THE SECOND
YEAR IN A ROW- BEEN SELECTED TO
BE PART OF. THE PROTONS.
HOUSING PACKAGE AND I'M HONORED
THAT SENATOR ATKINS HAS SIGNED
ON AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF
ISSUE TIME I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. THIS
LEGISLATION INCENTIVIZES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. OUGHT TO
CONCENTRATE ON NEW HOUSING
MULTI UNIT HOUSING AND- INFILL-
AND JOB IN TRANSIT RICH OUR
COMMUNITIES. BY GIVING SEE WHAT
RELIEF TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DECISION TO ADOPT- A NEW ZONING
FOR UP TO TEN UNITS IN NON
SEVERAL AREAS. TO BE CLEAR
SENATE BILL TEN IS A PURE LOCAL
CONTROL BILL. THAT PROVIDES
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA WITH A
VOLUNTARY- AND AFFECT VERY
EFFECTIVE TOOL THAT THEY CAN
CHOOSE TO USE. OR NOT USE- TO
ENGAGE AN. MORE EXPEDITIOUS
REZONING. IT FOR CITY TO NOT TO
USE OUR SPEED IT WILL THAT HAVE
NO IN ON THAT CITY. DIVERSITY
DECIDES THAT A FEW TIMES
APPROPRIATE THE CITY CAN OFTEN
AND USE THIS TOOL TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY ON STONE- IT'S
COMMUNITY AND DECIDE ON WHERE
AND HOW AND WHETHER TO DO IT
TEN UNITS OR UNITS ARE FOUR
UNITS OR ANYTHING ELSE- THERE
IS A- TIMES. I THINK. CITIES
GET BROAD BRUSHED. AS A NEW
CITIES EVER WANTING TO
INCREASE. ZONES DENSITY- AND
WHILE THERE ARE CITIES
CERTAINLY PLAYED CITIES THAT DO
NOT WANT TO THERE ARE ALSO
PLENTY OF CITIES. TWO ONE TWO
ZERO ONE FOR MORE HOUSING. BUT
WE MAKE IT INCREDIBLY HARD FOR
THEM TO DO SO AND WE MAKE THEM
SOMETIMES EVEN AFFAIRS OWNING.
IN A VERY ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE WAY YOUR JOBS YOUR
TRANSIT AND EXISTING INFILL
AREAS. WE MAKE THEM GO THROUGH
A VERY VERY LENGTHY. PROCESS SB
TEN ALLOW CITIES TO STREAMLINE
REZONING FOR UP TO TEN UNIT.
BUILDINGS IF THEY CHOOSE. THE
BILL. ONLY APPLIES TO YOUR
TRANSIT AND JOB RICH AREAS OR
URBAN AND SELF- ON THE BILL
REALLY HAS POTENTIAL TO EMPOWER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PURSUE
MORE EQUITABLE. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE USE OF THIS MISSING
MIDDLE ARE KIND OF HOUSING- I
WANT TO BE. CLEAR THAT SB TEN
DOES NOT CHANGE HOW INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS. ARE APPROVED- THIS IS
ABOUT THE ZONING EACH PROJECT
WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
WHATEVER THE NORMAL APPROVAL
PROCESS IS GOVERNED BY EITHER
LOCAL OR STATE LAW. ON CITIES
WILL HAVE THE OPTION THEY CAN
MAKE. A MINISTERIAL APPROVAL IF
THEY CHOOSE ARE THEY CAN MAKE
A- DISCRETIONARY WHICH IS
CURRENTLY THE LAW. SIGNED SO
ARE WITH ME TODAY- TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OUR
GILROY CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
ACREE HILTON- AND LUIS MORA
TODAY FROM CALIFORNIA YIMBY-
OUR SPONSOR I THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THROUGH OUR LEAD WITNESS
A PLEASE BEGIN. A GOOD
AFTERNOON BYE BYE SURE NUMBER
MY NAME IS LOUIS MANTE AND I'M
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BE HAPPY TO BE HERE
TODAY IF BOTH SPONSOR THAT YOU
CAN. OF COMMUNITY WORK WITH
DOESN'T SEEM TO BELIEVE IT.
ASIAN ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
PURSUIT OF LINK OUT THIS. THREE
POINT FIVE HOME SHORTAGE. AND
TO ACT OTHER. OF THE. YOU CAN.
ALL THE MORE CLEAR BY THE
NINETEEN. MANY OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS DURING GAME AND
AFTER FOR DENSITY UP CODING THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND WAY TO THEIR
LOCAL HOUSING SHORTAGES FOR
EXAMPLE OUR PARTNERS IN THE
SACRAMENTO. DISCO DISCO AND I
THINK WE'LL THAT HE NUMEROUS
OTHER ACROSS CALIFORNIA HARPER
OR CONSIDERING. OPTIONAL ORDER
THAT WOULD ALLOW BACK TO NOT
GET ANY BE AND GET NOW GIVE
THEM OUR FULL WILL TO ALLOW FOR
THE REGARDING AT MUCH CHEAPER
AND FASTER RATE AT IS BEING
RECORDED WITH THE LOOK ABOUT
ELECTIONS. I THINK WHAT
ORDINANCE ARE FOR MANY REASONS
HELP LOCALLY BE COMPLY WITH
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS THEY ADD
MUCH POWER BECAUSE- AND TO JUST
MAKING GENERALLY HELPS OUT WHEN
BURKE BUT MR AND CRY PRACTICE
OF RACIAL. BUT LOOK AT DINING
AT THE BUCKLEY ACCOMPLISH. OUR
MIDDLE QUALITY ACT. SENATOR
INTERVENTION ORDINANCES WILL
REMAIN OPTIONAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. IN MANY PLACES
THAT I CALL THE REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT
PROCESS WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
AGENCY TO INCREASE THEIR DON'T
ASK ME TO MEET THEIR HOUSING
GOALS IN THE- THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THEM TO DO SO MORE
EFFECTIVELY BRINGING THEM INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE HOUSING
ELEMENT IN A MUCH CHEAPER AND
I'M MATTER. IT INCLUDES A NOTE
UNDER WE ARE DEAD I BET THIS
BILL DOES NOT ESTABLISH A
PROJECT MAKES PRETTY MUCH IT
ONLY FUNCTIONS ONLY FUNCTION TO
ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES BUT NOT
REQUIRE THEM BUT NOT BEEN MORE
THAN THAT ALLOWS FOR MORE
HAPPENING UP TO TEN YEARS AGO.
SB TEN WILL HELP CALIFORNIA AND
OUTGOING PERSON. AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR. THANK YOU
MISTER. A SECOND LEAVE WITNESS.
OF MISTER MERON J. ARE YOU A
THE PHONE THAT WAS AROUND HE'S
GAZING. HILL HELLO VICE CHAIR
MA'AM. OF THE PUBLIC. I AM DOC
WILL BE READY OF YOUR HELLO
HOUSE ADVOCATES AND I GO CITY
MEMBER WE ARE IN A HOUSING FOR.
IN THE OF OWNING A HOME IS NOT
EVERY. OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYONE
WE MUST CONTINUE TO PROMOTE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR ALL INCOME LEVELS
BY LOOKING TOWARDS CREATIVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE SB TEN. I HAVE
HAD STRUGGLES WITH HOUSING AS
OUR LITTLE FAMILY GREW. AS A
FIREFIGHTER IN THE EAST BAY I
WASN'T ABLE TO A FORM. OF
FLORIDA HOME WHERE I WORK. I AM
STILL WORKING IN THE EAST BAY
AND THE CAN YOU CAN SOMETIMES
BE AN HOUR AND A HALF OR
LONGER. OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
OUR EXPERIENCE WITH HOUSING AND
LET ME TO BECOME A HOUSING
ADVOCATE ENJOYING OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND ORGANIZATIONS
AROUND THE REGION. INVOLVING
THAT HOUSING PRICES. NEXT READ
IF I COULD GET IT. SOME
CREATIVITY ON HOW THE
PRODUCTION. THAT INCLUDES SMALL
PROJECTS THE BIG ONE. WE CAN'T
GROW IN A MAJORITY OF OUR LAND
IS DONE FOR SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES. AT A LOCAL LEVEL AND GO
RIGHT IT'S ALREADY BEEN
MENTIONED MEETINGS THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT ME. IN THE MIDDLE
HOUSING YOU BOXES TRIED BUT
THEN FOUR BOXES. CALIFORNIA HAS
DESCENDED INTO A SUFFOCATING
HOUSING CRISIS. CONTRIBUTED TO
MASS MIGRATION OUT OF STATE.
SPIRAX NEED A BIG RATES. LOW
CRIME MOST AND AGREE. CLASS OF
LOWERING COMPUTERS. UNABLE TO
AFFORD ACTIVE HOUSING WITHIN
SEVERAL HOURS THEIR JOB. SB
CANDIDATE SIMPLE BILL THAT
AUTHORIZED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
REZONE NEIGHBORHOODS SPRING
CREEK HOUSING DENSITY UP TO TEN
HOMES FOR PARCEL. IT OUT THERE
IS ATION WILL REQUIRE THAT A
LEGISLATIVE BODY POPPING
ORDINANCE TO ADOPT. THE PLAN.
AND EXEMPT THAT DON'T NEED
ACTION FROM BEING CONSIDERED. A
PROJECT ENERGY KALRA I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT SB TEN WHICH IS NOT
CHANGED LOCAL HEIGHT LIMIT THAT
BACK OBJECTIVE DESIGN
STANDARDS. HISTORIC CENTER
DEMOLITION RESTRICTION. SB CAN
CREATE THE PATH TO ADD A MODEST
ENTITY. TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING SHORTAGE PRESERVES
SIGNIFICANT LOCAL CONTROL LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TAKE THAT ****
BUT THE DEFENSIVE IN LESS RICH
DIVERSITY TO UNDERTAKING. THE
PROCESS TO INCREASE DENSITY IN
OUR COMMUNITY. SB TEN IS AN
EFFECTIVE STEP IN PICKING WHAT
HAS BEEN A HISTORIC PROBLEM
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE.
THANK YOU ANY CONCLUSION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BUT-
THANK YOU NOW GO TO ON THOSE.
WHO ENGAGE WITNESS THAT WE TO
OF TOWN. SO THE MIGHT BE FORTY
TWO AUTHOR. ANYONE OF. ON THE
MIKE. STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. BATUM CHARLOTTE
STORES WITH STRATEGIES TO SIXTY
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES ALL
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SEE ANY OTHERS. AND HERE THEY
WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY DO
WE HAVE ANY ONE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT THREE NINE THEN AERICA
MODERATOR WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND JOB OPEN THOSE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE WAITING A
TELECONFERENCE TO. SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND AGAIN WE ARE
ALLOWING FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE- TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY AND PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION SO
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND- LET
ME KNOW HOW MANY WE HAVE IN Q.
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ON
OUR TELECONFERENCING LINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE IN Q. DOWN ON THE BEACH
INDIVIDUAL OUR WILL TO STATE
THEIR NAME AND THEIR
AFFILIATION AND WE WILL NEED TO
OUR TERMINATE AT OUR WILL WITH
THE FIFTEEN SPEAKER BUT I'D
LIKE TO REMIND THOSE WHO ARE
WAITING ON THE LINE OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL SB TEN WILL
HAVE ANOTHER HEARING. HERE NO
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IF IT IS
PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE SO
THEY WOULD HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR
OF FAR WE DON'T GET TO THEM
TODAY SO LET'S BEGIN. I AM
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
FIRST SPEAKER. THANK YOU I'M
THREE CATEGORIES GO AHEAD. HI
I'M DAVID WALKER CALLING FROM
NOW ON YOU CAN BE SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTEEN IN SUPPORT OF
TECH OKAY. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ARMAMENTS ROCK BOTTOM FELL IN
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BOOK IF HE
ACTION AS WELL AS AN INCREASE
IN THE IMPROPER THE COURT.
THANK YOU I'M TO TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOLLY FOR MANY
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF- SB AT HOME HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA THE
COUNCIL OF INFILL BUILDERS CAN
HELP PROPERTIES TMG PARTNERS
AND THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE TIMES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHERA WILL BE
REGIONAL ORGANIZER WITHOUT
FRANCISCO UNITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT THE TEN. THANK
YOU I'M THRILLED TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE MY NAME IS TONY DE
TRINIDAD I'M ACTUALLY CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION SB TEN
WILL NEED LANGUAGE THAT SUPPORT
QUALITY JOBS NOT JUST JOBS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
OF I NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS OUT OF MEDAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN THE QUARTERBACK YOU CAN'T
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWO
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ALFRED YOU CALLING WITH EBAY
FOR EVERYONE AND WE ARE IN
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M ONE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MARJANI FROM LOS ANGELES
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ABUNDANT
HOUSING LA AND MUCH BETTER FOR
EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE TO TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS JORDAN CRIMES OF SAN
MATTEO ON BEHALF OF PENINSULA
YOUNG DEMOCRATS STRONG SUPPORT
ABOUT TEN WHICH EXPANDED LOCAL
CONTROL FOR RESPONSIBLE CITIES.
THANK YOU I'M TWO THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KEVIN ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
REPRESENTING IN THE LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M
TO SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE FAN ON BEHALF OF
BRIDGE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M THREE OH SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LIKE MONEY
GONNA BE HAPPY THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR AVAILABLE ON BEHALF OF THE
COLLEGE UNIVERSITY POLICING.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AND THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ALWAYS WHAT. THANK YOU RYAN
THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ARGHA
CAUGHT SOMEONE AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF ABANDONED HOUSING.
AND I'M ANY STOP ORDER SB TEN.
THANK YOU I'M THREE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DAN AND ALL A CROW AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT TODAY WITH
THE BUTTON HOUSING LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. THE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
VINCE CROCE WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP CALLING
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT INTO TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO ONE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BLAME THREE SEVENTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YES ON THE
SUBSTANCE ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY VETERANS AND
MILITARY FAMILIES COLLABORATIVE
HOUSING COMMITTEE- PLEASE
SUPPORT SB TEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU APPLYING ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE ONE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THREE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KEVIN MA AND WHAT
THE NETWORK WHERE EVERYONE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU NINE THREE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS SID
COULD WORK WITH ANY STATE FOR
EVERYONE- IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME GOING TO CHRISTOPOULOS
COMMISSIONER THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA PRESIDENT OF THE
DOWNTOWN NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THAT WE CAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THREE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ZACH BOLLINGER-
MEDIAN WITH IN THE ACTION IN
THE BAY AND ITEMS FROM ORDERS
THAT'S BECAUSE- THANK YOU I'M
TO NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY LOOK GENERATION HOUSING-
BASE OF CINEMA COUNTY ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M
THREE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT THREE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
HEALTHY BRAIN QUIZ IN THE
ACTION AND PENINSULA FOR
EVERYONE IN THE PARK. THANK YOU
I'M THREE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S JOSH I
RECOMMEND WITH SOUTH PASADENA
RESIDENTS PER
RESPONSE-GOVERNORS WE ARE
STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
I'M THREE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS HOLLY FOR
MEANING AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF BOB NAYLOR AND THE
FIELD THE COMPANY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELLING CALVING
TROUBLE DIALING IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON SERRA-
WILL BE WITH IT REGIONAL
ORGANIZER REPRESENTING SAN
FRANCISCO AGAIN BEAT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE OH SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO TWELVE
I'M- WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR THEN WE WILL GO IF
THERE'S NO ONE ADDITIONAL THAT
WANTS TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
SPEAKER ERIN LEHANE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO LOSE HERE IN FORTY TWO
OR THREE. AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES YEAH. A GOOD AFTERNOON
AGAIN- I APPEAR BEFORE YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT COUNCIL
OF IRON WORKERS INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS AND
THEN NEARLY HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL TEN. WE ARE HONORED
THE SESSION TO BE WORKING WITH
SO MANY LEGISLATORS WHO SEEK TO%
SUPPORT THE HARD WORKING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AND
APPRENTICES THAT WE REPRESENT.
BRINGING US PROACTIVE
PROACTIVELY BRINGING US
LEGISLATION THAT CREATES JOBS
PROTECTS EXISTING JOBS. I
RECOGNIZE IS THE EXTREME
STRUGGLE THE MOST WORKING
FAMILIES FACE ON A DAILY BASIS
TO PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE. AND A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT ALTHOUGH NO
RELATIONSHIP IS PERFECT IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE NEED
TO SHARE A BASIC IDEOLOGY AS IT
COMES TO WORKING FAMILIES. SB
TEN IS NOT ABOUT WORKING
FAMILIES. IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
ANY LABOR STANDARDS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR WORKING PEOPLE. IT CREATES
A STREAMLINED PROCESS SAVING
DEVELOPERS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WITHOUT PROVIDING A
CORRESPONDING PUBLIC BENEFIT.
SB TEN WILL BE A GIFT TO
PROFITEERING HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND CREATE MARKET RATE MOSTLY
INFILL DEVELOPMENT IGNORING
CALIFORNIA'S NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
EQUITABLE WAGES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE SOMEONE
ELSE- ARE SERGEANTS AND-
PROCESS. MISTER IN OPPOSITION
STATE YOUR NAME AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM VICE CHAIR MIKE
WEST ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NOW WILL GO TO
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL- INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE WISH SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO S. B. TEN C.
NINE. THEN ON MATAMATA READER
LET US GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCING LINE AND OPEN
OUT FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TEN- AND PLEASE LET ME KNOW HOW
MANY WE HAVE IN QUEUE. THEY
WILL ALSO HAVE FIFTEEN MINUTES
TO SPEAK AND OUR STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION AND AGAIN
I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU- IF
YOU'RE IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
MAKE IT INTO THIS FIFTEEN
MINUTE. PRESENTATION OF DOWN
THERE IS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY-
IF THE BILL MOVES TO GOVERNMENT
AND FINANCE. SO MADAM MODERATOR
IF YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIFTY OR
MORE IN Q. BY FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE NEW. WHY FOUR
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. PINE TO
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ROBERT WIENER BEEN ALLIED
TRADES DISTRICT COUNCIL THIRTY
SIX STRONGLY STANDING WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES WELL THE MOST
MEASURE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHILDREN SEE
AND REMEMBER THIS PRESIDENT OF
THE NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING TRADES ON BEHALF OF
OUR THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THE SP TEN.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO ALTER-PLEASE AHEAD. AND BY MANY AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA OF LOCAL ELECTED
OPPOSE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON M. AS PRIMARILY AT
THE IRON WORKERS LOCAL FOUR
THIRTY THREE AND- WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES AND
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS EVANS
WITH CARPENTERS LOCAL TWO SIX
SEVENTEEN IN SAN MATEO COUNTY.
HERE TO VOICE STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL TEN. THANK YOU
I'M THREE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS TOMMY
QUALIFY REPRESENT IBEW LOCAL UP
IN LOS ANGELES- WE STAND
OPPOSED TO THE S. B. TEN
BECAUSE OF THERE IS NO WORK
STANDARDS. AND BEST PRACTICES
IN PLACE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M TO FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM SURE MEMBER SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITED HERE
STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
TO NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ARGUE BELCHER I WOULD
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CARPENTERS
REGIONAL COUNCIL WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSE
SB TEN. THANK YOU I'M THREE OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
ANASTASI OF ANNAPOLIS MEMBER OF
SAN FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION IN
OPPOSITION TO. S. B. HAN THANK
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE SEVENTY
THREE IS GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MORE DELIVERY
CORPORATE LOCAL. FORTY SIX
NINETY ONE NINE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY NINE. AND WE STEM THE
BILLION TRADED STRONGLY. SENATE
BILL CAN. THANK YOU I NINETY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD RECORDER LOCAL SEVEN
THIRTEEN COVERING ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE SB TURN.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SUNSET
PARKSIDE EDUCATION ACTION
COMMITTEE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CHEN MEMBERS MATT KREMIN
SHALL BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA
NEVADA CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU I ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. VERY GOOD THANK YOU TO
HELP NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS CONSTRUCTION
COMMITTEE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WENT
DOWN THERE FOR THE LAFAYETTE I
AM NOT A MEMBER OF HOPPING ON
AND LOCAL LESSONS BY INCLUDING
BUT NOT FOR THE COUNCIL SHOULD
BE ABLE TO OVERRIDE. THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE AND HAVE NOT
AFFORDABILITY COMPONENT I THINK.
SH THANK YOU I'M. ONE FIFTY
NINE FOUR. NINE ONE FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HE WRITES CARPENTERS LOCAL
TWENTY TWO WE STANDING IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOING MOBILE OF
IRONWORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT ENDING WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO HELLO YES PATRICK
POLO OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
THREE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I'M THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS MY GREEN
LINK WITH FISHER CAL SIXTEEN
INTERNATIONAL YOU'RE A PAIR
DOLLAR TRADES WITHOUT THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES OPPOSITION
ABOUT THAT. THANK YOU RYAN.
THREE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HI DAVID QUINTANA
FOR THE COMMUNITY OF LIMERICK
PARK IN THE CITY OF HIDDEN HELD
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF
CATALYSTS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
IT'S ROBIN GREENBERG PRESIDENT
OF THE BEL AIR BEVERLY CREST
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL AND
SECRETARY THE WESTSIDE REGIONAL
ALLIANCE COUNCIL ALLIANCE
SUPPORT THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND
COMMUNITY COUNCILS ON THE WEST
SIDE OF LOS ANGELES WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE BECAUSE WE DO NOT FEEL
THAT IT IS PROPER TO NOT
INCLUDE A VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES. CAUGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. VALERIE
HIGHNESS THEY WERE LOCAL TO GO
BADLY NEIGHBORHOODS LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN WHAT SHORT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE ZERO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I AM
THRILLED FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE CALLING
ON THE HELP AVAILABILITY
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AS PART
OF THE HUNDRED QUESTION NOTED
NEIGHBORS ASSOCIATION STRONGLY
OPPOSED IN THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN AT THREE
TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
THREE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF STEVE ALONG
WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THREE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HERE'S A MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRISTY CORRELATE WITH KATELYN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AS YOU CAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I AM TO
SIX CA PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
AMY GALA DAY I BELONG TO
GREATER FAIRFAX RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION AND BEVERLY
WILSHIRE HOME OWNERS AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S. B. TEN
THERE IS NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND T'S A LAND GRAB FOR
DEVELOPERS SO THEY CAN USE ANY.
MEANS THAT THEY CAN TO PUT UP
LUXURY HOUSING AND NOTHING
NOTHING FOR AFFORDABLE IN FACT
THEY CARED THAT MODEM BAKLEY'S%
LANI JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF MINE CHIU FORTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO
FOUR SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE THREE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ONE EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND ONE
EIGHT CHECK PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE TWO EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MILADY TEAMSTERS TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU RIGHT THIRTY THREE
GLAD. VIRGINIA MCCARTY MEDINA
PARK ASSOCIATION LEAGUE
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TEN COOKING
AWAY ANY INITIATIVES THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN BETTER IF ENACTED.
STRONGLY PART. THANK YOU I'M
THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MARK RODRIGUEZ
WORKERS LOCAL OR THIRTY THREE
WE STAND IN STRONG OPPOSITION
ALONG WITH THIS STATE BUILDING
TRADES. THANK YOU I'M TO A-
FLAT. TWO EIGHT ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD HELLO. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH UP MIDDLE SINGLE
FAMILY MONICA AND WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M CHIU
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
HOUSES GREG LEWIS WITH THE
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
SEVEN SIXTY ONE WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB TEN. THANK YOU I'M
THREE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CRANE SHARE OF NORTHEAST
NEIGHBORS OF SANTA MONICA SANTA
MONICA CITY COUNCIL UNANIMOUSLY
OPPOSES SB TEN WHICH ALLOWS
CITIES TO OVERTURN VOTER
INITIATIVES AND IGNORES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M TWO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GONZALEZ
AT RISK OF BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
STILL STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOUR MIND
ONE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE ONE SEVEN THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THREE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AND
GREENSPON A BOARD MEMBER OF
SANTA MONICA NORTH MONTANA
ASSOCIATION WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL UNITS AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SB TEN
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
TRULY AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KAREN BYRNE WITH THE MONEY YOU
KNOW IT'S BOTH YEAH YOU CAN IN
UNITED NEIGHBORS WE OPPOSE SB
TEN NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING NO
TENSION FROM HIGH FIRE ZONE AND
IT LOOKS LIKE A GIVEAWAY TO
DEVELOPERS. THANK YOU I ONE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CURRENTLY NOT
GOOD GALA RESIDENTS SUNNYVALE
CODES AT THE TEN. MY ALLOWING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO OVERRIDE.
THEY SHOULD CHECK THAT THE BAD
PRESS IN ERODE VOTER TRUST IN
GOD THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE BY ONE EIGHT
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARK TO BUILD
THE EVEN PROSECUTE PLAYERS
LOCAL SIXTEEN AND WE STAND INS
THE BILL SIGNALING TRADES
INSTRUCTION OPPOSITION TO THE
SP TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TWO SEVEN FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THREE
AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD MAILING
STEPHENS ON BEHALF OF SUNNYVALE
UNITED NEIGHBORS STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU I'M TWO FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY
NAME IS JOHN SPALDING
REPRESENTING THE CARD IN YOUR
MODEL COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN THEIR STRONG
OPPOSITION SB YEAH. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN ONE
THREE SEVEN PLEASE CALL AT. ONE
ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE NINE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY THREE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
RANDALL MADE WITH DISTRICT HELP
WITH PAIRS AND ALLIED TRADES WE
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION TO ASK B. YEAH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BY THREE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES WE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OF I WON SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY THREE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SPERRY OF MOUNTAIN VIEW UNITED
NEIGHBORS AYE OPPOSED THREE AND
R. S. B. IT PROVIDES A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR MONEY IN
POLITICS TWO BY COUNCIL MEMBERS
AND THE OVERRIDE AND CENTRIST.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD OR GILBERTVILLE
RESIDENTS CROSS CITY FOR SAFETY
AND SANITY AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
SANTA MONICA ORGANIZATIONS
STRONGLY OPPOSES THAT BEGAN
INCREASING MARKET WE DEFINITELY
WILL NOT ADDRESS THE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS. DON'T
FIND LOCAL VOTER BALLOT
INITIATIVE PROCESS IS
UNDEMOCRATIC AND UNACCEPTABLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PINE TO NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO NINE
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN.
ONE ONE ONE NINE ONE. HELLO
OKAY. YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH
PROBABLY LOOK WE DON'T WANT TO
REPRESENTING OUR COUNTY ON THE
YOU ARE STARTING YOUR- THANK
YOU YOU'RE A NINE POINT LEAD AT
MATAMATA MOTOR LET ME LET ME
INTERRUPT TESTIMONY WE ARE
GETTING A LOT OF FEEDBACK DATA
DUPLICATION WHEN SOMEONE SAYS.
BOB HOW TO POSE THOSE OPPOSE
OPPOSE OPPOSE COULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK. YEAH SEE WHAT WHAT
PROBLEM OUT. WE WEREN'T HERE
RIGHT OVER THE PHONE.
THREE
ONE. HOW MUCH TIME LEFT I HAVE
LANDLINE WILL KILL YOU YOUR
DIRECTOR DIRECTOR. YEAH WHEN.
TO PLEASE THE WORK. ON THE
WORST DRIVING YEAH. YEAH
EXACTLY WHAT NORMAN. ONE DOLLAR.
EVERYBODYYOUR POST BACK ON
THIS PROBLEM. OKAY. WE CAN.
WE
WILL TAKE A FIVE MINUTE RECESS
WHILE THERE ARE TEMPTING TO LOG
ON TO FIX THE A TELECONFERENCE.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT GREAT
GREAT GREAT. OUR SYSTEM IS YOUR
LIFE THINGS ARE.
MINUTES ADDITIONAL TIME FOR
TESTIMONY R. AS WE TOOK TIME-
TRYING TO FIX THE
TELECONFERENCING SO LET'S BEGIN
AGAIN WITH OUR OUR NEXT OF
COLOR. THANK YOU I CURRENTLY
HAVE FOR IN Q. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE THREE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LET ME GET ONE YEAH WHY
ONE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY CRISTERO THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
THREE- BUT WHAT THE AUTHOR
ABOUT SCHOOL ENTERING WORK
FORCE AND THE BUILDING TRADES-
LAST AUGUST- HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET THAT IN THERE BUT AT THIS
POINT WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED
UNLESS WE GET SOME LABOR
STANDARDS ACTUALLY IN THERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT ONE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE PRESENTERS
WE YOUR CENTERS WHICH ARE NOT
DISAPPEARED OUT OF SIGHT YES
WHITE WHITE SEVEN TWO NOTE BUT
WHEN THEY ALLOW TO CONNECT WITH
INTERNATIONAL ABOUT THE
ENGINEER LOCAL- THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO HEAR CYCLE
STANCE THE STATE BILL TRADES IN
STRONG UP BEST BE TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO NINE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR. ONE TWO NINE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO SEVEN FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. YEAH I
WAS GLAD OKAY THANK YOU HI MY
NAME'S HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
CALLING IN WHICH CALIFORNIA
YIMBY TO SUPPORT- SB TEN AND SB
NINE APOLOGIES IF I'M IN THE
WRONG SECTION BUT I JUST GOT
OFF ANOTHER CALL SO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
I DO HAVE TWO COMMENTS THAT
JUST POPPED IN Q. RIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
RON MILLER ON BEHALF OF THE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND SKILLED
AND TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE LA ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH YOUR PHONE
SYSTEM DIFFICULTY RIGHT NOW NO
ONE EVER COME ON AND GIVE ME A
NUMBER SO THERE MAY BE SOME
OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO
GET AND I CAN'T BUT IN ANY
CASE- I MY NAME IS KRISTEN
RASMUSSEN I'M NOT REPRESENTING
THE BURDEN ABOUT A
NEIGHBORHOODS GREAT AND ALSO-
IN. RESPONSE UNITED NEIGHBORS
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB TEN.
THANK YOU. OUR MODERATOR I THAT
WE REACHES LIMIT ON THE OFF I'D
LIKE TO AGAIN REMIND THOSE WHO
MIGHT BE WAITING IN THE QUEUE
ON THIS BILL ARE IF PASSED FROM
THIS COMMITTEE. WILL GO TO
ANOTHER COMMITTEE WHERE YOU'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO AGAIN I
REGISTER ON. YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SO WITHOUT TRIAL I'M
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE-
COMMITTEE. FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THEM IF YOU HAVE
VANTAGE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING CHAIR VENTURE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR. THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A TO RETURN
THIS. THANK YOU SO MUCH AT THE
CENTER WIENER DIMANA JUST ON
THE ISSUE OF AFFORDABLE. ON SB
TEN LAST YEAR YOU WORKED ON
ENSURING THAT THIS BILL IS
FOCUSED BOTH ON AFFORDABLE AS
WELL AS MARKET RATE DEVELOPMENT
IF YOU COULD JUST PLEASE
CLARIFY THAT THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED. R. SURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOHN SENATE
MCGUIRE- THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STAND THIS BILL IS
ABOUT SMALL BUILDINGS. TWO
THREE FOUR SIX EIGHT UP TO TEN
UNIT- BUILDINGS- IF- AND THOSE
CAN BE EITHER BELOW MARKET RATE
WILL RECALL AFFORDABLE OR
MARKET RATE OR A MIX OF THE
TWO- IN ADDITION ANY- ANY
LOCAL. INCLUSIONARY OF THE CITY
HAS ITS OWN REQUIREMENTS THAT
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF UNITS
HAVE TO BE AFFORDABLE TO A
CERTAIN INCOME BRACKET THAT
WOULD APPLY TO THIS BILL THIS
BILL DOES NOT. CHANGE LOCAL
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS
LOCAL LOCAL HEIGHT LIMITS LOCAL
SETBACKS ANYTHING LIKE THAT
THIS BILL DIFFERS TO LOCAL
DECISIONS THIS IS A LOCAL
DECISION MAKING. THE BILL BUT
THE BILL DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
PREVENT AFFORDABLE HOUSING FROM
BEING BUILT PURSUANT TO AN S.
B. TIME. REZONING BENCHERS ONE
ISSUE QUESTION. GO AHEAD I
THOUGHT YOU WANTED THANK YOU SO
MUCH FURNITURE YEAH AND THEN
FOR THE AUTHOR- CENTER WIENER
THE OTHER ISSUE IS ON THE
VOLUNTARY WITH THIS IS
PROVIDING FOR EXAMPLE CITY
COUNCILS A TOOL TO BE ABLE TO
USE IT'S NOT MANDATORY BUT IF
THEY WANTED TO BE ABLE TO USE
THIS. THEY COULD UTILIZE THIS
IN YOUR COMMUNITY BUT IT WOULD
BE UP TO THAT COUNCIL CORRECT
CORRECT THIS IS A PURELY
VOLUNTARY TOOL CITY CAN IGNORE
ENTIRELY AND THEN IT HAS NO
EFFECT AT ALL IN THAT CITY- OR
THE CITY COUNCIL CAN DECIDE TO
UTILIZE- I THINK THEY'RE ONE OF
THE THINGS WE- PLACE
REQUIREMENTS ON CITIES AROUND
HOUSING AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT HOUSING IS A-
IMPORTANT STATEWIDE ISSUE AND-
THERE NEED TO BE STATEWIDE
STANDARDS FOR PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING- BUT WE ALSO. SOMETIMES
MAKE IT HARD ON CITIES WE DID
THAT WE TOOK REDEVELOPMENT AWAY
FOR EXAMPLE NONE AND WE TELL
CITIES WE WANT THEM TO REZONE
FOR MORE HOUSING IN SUSTAINABLE
AREAS BUT THEN WE MAKE A REALLY
LENGTHY AND EXPENSIVE AND
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO DO THAT
AS THE TIME IS GIVING US
VOLUNTARY TOOL FOR CITIES IF
THEY CHOOSE TO USE THAT. TO
HAVE A FASTER- AND- MORE- COST
EFFECTIVE. WAY OF DOING IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN THAT SAID
THERE'S SOME. ABOUT THAT AS
HAVE HAVE BEEN IN. NEEDS THAT.
CITY WOULD HAVE TO BE ADOPTED
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TURN
THANK YOU CENTER. THANK YOU.
THAT IS WHY CASTING. I'M SORRY
STEPPED OUT. THERE WAS ONE
CALLER ONE OF THE IN. THE
UNITED NEIGHBORHOOD- PEOPLE
THAT INDICATED THAT. THIS WORK
SALARY. DEVELOPMENT IN HIGH
FIRE ZONES A FIRE SINCE CAN YOU
CLARIFY THAT OR YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THE BILL
DOES YEAH I'M SORRY. AS I DO IN
THEM. PRINT ALL MY HOUSING
BILLS- I EXCLUDE AND SECLUDED
HERE THE- SO CALLED VERY HIGH.
FIRE ONE OF OUR SEVERITIES ARE
INSIDE THE HIGHEST TIER. OF
WILDFIRE SEVERITY. IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THIS BILL AND THAT.
IS THE SAME PROVISIONAL WE HAVE
HAD IN VARIOUS- IN OTHER
SENATE. BILLS AS WELL- THERE IS
A- A PROVISION IN IT THAT IF
THE FIRE MARSHAL. CERTIFIES
THAT A CERTAIN AREA BASICALLY
HAS THE SUPPLIERS SEVERITY RISK
HAS BEEN. REDUCED THEN THEY CAN
DO THAT BUT THE FIRE MARSHAL-
HOUSE TO CERTIFY THAT OTHERWISE
YOU CAN'T BUILDING THOSE ARMS.
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
OTHER SENATE HOUSING BILLS IN
TERMS OF HOW. WE FRAME THAT
EXEMPTION. WHAT. OH I'M SORRY
SKINNER IF. YEAH HE WAS
FINISHED SENATOR SKINNER SORRY
WE WERE FINISHED CRAP. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ARM. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
ABOUT THE BILL- FIVE THE
OPPOSITION THAT CALLED IN WE
CLEARLY KNOW THAT THERE ARE
RESIDENTS IN COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO- ARE.
VERY VERY RESISTANT TO ZONING
CHANGES. BUT I WANT TO NOTE
THAT. A GOOD REASON OR IT COULD
BE. A LARGE PART OF WHY WE HAVE
SUCH A HOUSING SUPPLY SHORTAGE
IS BECAUSE OF THE EXTENSIVE
AMOUNT OF LAND WITHIN OUR URBAN
AND SUBURBAN AREAS THAT ARE.
ZONED SINGLE FAMILY AND ONLY
SINGLE FAMILY AND AS A RESULT
WE'VE RESTRICTED THOSE
RESTRICTIONS HAVE LEFT SUCH
LITTLE WAY ON ESPECIALLY IN OUR
JOB RICH AREAS AND TRANSIT
AREAS AS THIS BILL PUTS OUT. TO
BE- MULTI FAMILY OF ANY SIZE.
AND WE HAVE GROWN IN JOBS IN
GROWN IN POPULATION THAT WE
HAVE THIS TERRIBLE HOUSING
SHORTAGE IT ISN'T THAT WE
HAVEN'T HAD INVESTORS WILLING
TO BUILD HOUSING IT ISN'T FOR
THEIR SO MANY OTHER REASONS
WE'VE HAD LOTS OF DESIRE WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BUY
HOUSING WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO LIVE- WHO NOT PAY AS MUCH.
FOR THE HOUSING THAT THEY HAVE
AND THIS SHORTAGE HAS CREATED
ALSO ARE AFFORDABILITY PROBLEMS
SO I THINK THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE MEASURE BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES. THAT VERY
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE OF ENABLING
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO SO
CHOOSE TO BE ABLE TO REZONE
SOME OF THOSE PARCELS IF THEY
ARE IN THESE TYPES OF AREAS.
NOW I AM. I WAS- IT'S HARD TO
HEAR ARE GOOD COLLEAGUES IN THE
BUILDING TRADES SO- UNANIMOUSLY
OPPOSE THE BILL MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE WAS
DISCUSSION AND THERE WERE SOME-
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD- HAVE
THEM BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
BUT EVEN WITH THOSE PROVISIONS
THEY HAVE CHOSEN NOW TO OPPOSE
AND I HOPETHAT WE CAN GET TO A
GOOD MEETING OF THE MINDS
HOWEVER I THINK THIS IS STILL A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL. AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY. CENTER
SENATOR WHICH'LL BOOK. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR IF I MAY YEAH. I
RECEIVED A LOT OF LETTERS OF
CONCERN WITH THIS BILL FROM
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS- AND
MOST OF WHAT I SEE THE
UNDERLYING THEME IS THE FEAR OF
THE- LOSING THE INTEGRITY OF
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES SPECIALLY
RESIDENTIAL AREAS. WOULD YOU
CLARIFY I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
WOULD ALLOW FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD RECOMMEND THE FACT THAT
YOU ARE- AUTHORIZING NOT
MANDATING OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS I THINK THAT IS
THAT IS COMMENDABLE AND
RESPECTABLE. ON THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE COMING FROM
MY AREA I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE
LACK OF HOUSING PERIOD IS HUGE.
AND SO ON THAT END AND
APPRECIATE LOCAL CONTROL
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
ACCOMMODATED THAT. INDEED- IN
THIS BILL- WITH REGARDS THE
CONSTRUCTION WOULD YOU BECAUSE
WE ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS URBAN
AND WHAT IS- SUBURBAN AND RURAL
WOULD YOU. BE ABLE TO DEFINE AS
TO WHEN YOU IN THIS BILL WHAT
EXACTLY DO YOU UNDERSTAND BY.
URBAN INFILL SO THAT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS CAN UNDERSTAND WHETHER
OR NOT IT AFFECTS THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
SIR URBAN INTO THEIR THEIR
ARCHES A SPECIFIC DEFINITION I
AM LONG WE ARE SUCH AS A IT
TOOK TO FIND. FREEZE AND I CAN.
PULL IT UP BUT IT'S BEEN USED
IN OTHER CONTEXTS TO BOND AND
IT'S BASICALLY- AREAS WHERE IT
IS LIKE. ARE LIKE WELL
DEVELOPED AND IT'S NOT. OPEN
SPACE AND- IT'S NOT IN THE
MIDDLE OF LIKE A WILDERNESS
AREA- IT'S LIKE AREAS WHERE
IT'S LIKE A LIKE A COMPACT.
COMMUNITY THAT IS LIKE. I HATE
THE PHRASE BUILT. BUT ARE LEAST
TO AN EXTENT BUILT OUT- BUT
IT'S NOT JUST LIKE. AREAS WHERE
IT'S RANDOM NOT RAMBLE LIKE
HOMES SPORADICALLY EVERY NOW
AND AGAIN I WANT TO BE A MORE
RURAL SETTINGS- SO ARE THERE
SOME SUBURBS THAT WOULD. NOT
QUALIFY AS AN BUILDER SOME
SUBURBS OF WOMEN'S BECAUSE OUR
TO. SPREAD OUT FOR EACH OTHER
AND THE GOAL IS TO SAY YOU'RE
GONNA. EMPHASIZE MORE HOUSING
LET'S DO IT WHERE THERE'S
ALREADY. OTHER HOUSING BECAUSE
WHAT WE'VE IN CALIFORNIA-
DIFFERENT SO MUCH OPPOSITION TO
BUILDING IN AREAS WHERE THERE
ARE OTHER PEOPLE LIVING. WITH
HIS BILL TO FURTHER FURTHER AL
AND IT JUST CREATES- PROBLEMS
WITH YOU KNOW COVERING UP
FARMLAND AND- A LONGER COMMUTES
AND SO WE'RE TRYING T MAKE IT
A LITTLE MORE GIVEN THE TOOL TO
MAKE IT MORE CONTACT WE DON'T
WANT TO. HAVE SEX WITH
STREAMLINING FOR. BUILDING
FURTHER AND FURTHER OUT SO IT'S
REALLY CONTACT COMMUNITIES SO
WOULD THIS APPLY TO HOME OR
RESIDENTIAL AREAS WHERE PER SE.
YOU HAVE A RESIDENTIAL AREA
THAT ARE A COMMUNITY THAT
ENCOMPASSES AN AREA OR A LOT
SIZES OF. SAY SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED- FEET. BAKER IT COULD
NOT IT'S NOT BASED ON LOTS OF
IT'S BASED ON THE ARRAIGN OF
DEVELOPMENTS- AND WE CAN GET
YOU THE EXACT DEFINITION OF A
PERMANENT PHONE TRYING TO LOOK
IT UP RIGHT NOW- IT'S ON ARE.
EVER RAISE YOUR FIVE. BUT IT'S
BASICALLY THE U. S. CENSUS
ACTUALLY DEFINES WHAT INFILL
IS- IT'S A- IT'S CALLED
URBANIZED AREA OR AND URBAN
CLUSTER SO HAS TO BE SORT OF
CLUSTERED AGAIN NOT SORT OF
SPREAD OUT- IN ADDITION SO IT'S
ONE OF THE CLIMB BY THE CENSUS
AND OTHER ONE IS A SITE IN
WHICH WILL BE 75% OF THE
PERIMETER OF THE SITE THE JOINS
OTHER PARCELS RIGHT SO IT'S NOT
JUST LIKE BY ITSELF. HAS TO BE
A LOT AROUND OTHER PARCELS- AND-
A MATTER ALSO SO AS OWN PEROT.
USE OR RESIDENTIAL MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE GENERAL
PLAN DESIGNATION THAT ALLOWS
RESIDENTS FOR USE OR A MIX OF
RESIDENTIAL. AND NON
RESIDENTIAL OUR WORLD THESE TWO
THIRDS OF THE SQUARE FOOTAGE
HAS TO BE FOR RESIDENTIAL. FOR
THEIR ALL AREAS WERE LIKE AN
AREA OF WORK WHERE WE ARE
BURGER COMMUNITIES HAVE PLANS.
FOR HOUSING AND FOR THAT KIND
OF CONTINUOUS. KIND OF HOUSING-
SO THERE ARE A COUPLE DIFFERENT
WAYS A COUNTY UNTIL- AND THAT
IS OUR RIGHT AT THE END OF THE
BILL IS WERE URBAN INFILL- IS
TO FIND. OKAY AND I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE. IN NOT IT'S NOT
MANDATED AND THAT ARE AT THE
LOCAL PLANNING. COMMISSION
STILL HAVE JURISDICTION OVER-
THEIR LOCAL PLANNING AND
ZONING. SO THE BILL A COUPLE
THINGS HAVE TO HAPPEN UNDER
FIRST CITY COUNCIL HAS TO
DECIDE OFTEN. THAT THE CITY
COUNCIL DOESN'T KNOW ABOUT THE
BILL OR NOR IS IT ARE PROJECTS
OF HUNDRED OR JUST DECIDE NOT
DOING THAT. THE NOTHING HAPPENS
THE BILL IS NO OBLIGATION-
CITY. IF THE CITY COUNCIL
OPTION THE CITY COUNCIL THEN-
AS A CURRENTLY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DECIDE WHAT KIND
OF APPROVAL PROCESS THERE WILL
BE A COULD BE A FULL.
DISCRETIONARY PROCESS AND SEE
WHAT IT COULD BE A MINISTERIAL
APPROVAL PROCESS. AND THEN ONCE
THAT HAPPENS EACH AND EVERY
PROJECT WILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
WHATEVER. APPROVAL PROCESS. YOU
THE CITY HAS UP OR AND NOW
STATE. WHATEVER THE GOVERNING
LAW LOCAL STATE LAW IS FOR
APPROVAL WOULD APPLY TO EACH OF
THOSE PROJECTS WITH THIS BILL
DOES NOT. CHANGE WHAT THE
APPROVAL PROCESS WOULD BE
THAT'S WHATEVER THE CURRENT
GOVERNING LAW AS- WHICH
CLARIFIES WHETHER OR NOT.
INDIVIDUALS OR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS STILL HAVE A VOICE TO
COME IN AND GIVE THEIR VOICE TO
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS RIGHT
TODAY- COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL
HAVE A VOICE FIRST WHEN THIS IS
BEFORE THE CITY COUNCIL WILL BE
ABLE TO HAVE A VOICE. HI THERE
AND THEN BE EITHER HAPPY OR
UNHAPPY WITH CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS OVER THE VOTE- AND THEN
EACH INDIVIDUAL PROJECT.
WHATEVER THE APPROVAL PROCESS
IS NOT SOME CITIES HAVE. A
MINISTERIAL STREAMLINED
APPROVAL PROCESS AND NOT SIX
DECISION THAT THE CITY HAS MADE
THERE ARE SOME STATE LAWS THAT.
CAN REQUIRE THAT BUT- WHATEVER
YOU KNOW WHATEVER THE PROCESS
IS. FINE IF IT'S A
DISCRETIONARY PROCESS APPROVAL
PROCESS WHICH A LOT OF CITIES
HAVE. BEEN PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE FULLY I AM NOT
PROCESS PERFECT SO THIS
ACCOMMODATES THE FACT THAT
WE'RE NOT DOING A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WHERE
IT KNOWLEDGE IN THAT EACH
INDIVIDUAL ENTITY. COMMUNITY IS
UNIQUE. ABOUT THAT THAT'S
CORRECT BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO
CITY NOT ONLY DO CITIES GET TO
DECIDE. WHETHER THEY OPT IN OR
OPT OR OPT OUT AT ALL- ON THE
DAY. IF THEY OPT IN. VEGAS TO
DECIDE. WHERE INNER CITY. BAKER
SO THEY HAVE LOTS OF ENTIRE
CITY IS CONSIDERED AN FELT.
BIGGER SAY WE'RE JUST GOING TO
DO THIS ON THIS ONE STREET. OR
ONE NEIGHBORHOOD. FOUR ONE HALF
OF THE CITY OR THE WHOLE CITY
WHATEVER THE WHATEVER THEY
DECIDED TO DO- NO ONE WOULD BE
TELLING THEM. BUT HELL TO DO A
CITY WOULD BE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH ITS OWN VERSION OF IT THAT
YOU NEED TO THAT. OUR CITY AND
IN THE CITY- COULD DECIDE WE
WANTED TO BE A STREAMLINED
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL WE WANT TO
BE DISCRETIONARY YOU KNOW
UNLESS STATE LAW. DICTATES ONE
OR THE OTHER- AND THEN SO I
THINK THIS WILL IT WOULD LOOK.
PROBABLY FOR VERY DIFFERENT AND
EVERY CITY THAT DID IT. BECAUSE
DIFFERENT CITIES ARE GOING TO
PICK AND CHOOSE. WHERE WHERE TO
DO IT. OKAY PERFECT AND THEN
THE LAST- CONCERNED. THIS IS
NOT OVER RIGHT ANY. ANY- ANY
CODE THAT COMES FROM
CONSTRUCTION CODE- GOVERNMENTAL
CODE- LABOR CODES- ANY OF THAT
THE ONLY THING IS THAT THE
MAKING A CHANGES IS A SAYS THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
C. QUITE YEAH I OUR STREAMS
LINES IT MAKES IT LESS COSTLY
FOR THE ZONING- THAT DOTS THE
DOTS REALLY THE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN THE BILL- HI. IN
TERMS OF LAWN LABOR NO IT
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING- WITH
LABOR AND I JUST WANNA
KNOWLEDGE- YOU KNOW I'VE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH WITH THE BILL
INSURANCE FOR MANY YEARS ON
HOUSING AND HAVE PUT LABOR
PROTECTIONS AND BILLS BEFORE
AND I'VE HAD MAJOR HOUSING
BILLS THAT THE BUILDING TRADES
HAVE. STRONG SUPPORTED- ON ON
THIS BILL WE AS CENTER SKNNER
MENTIONED WE DID WORK WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES LAST YEAR WE
AGREED ON AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
RESULT IN THEM BEING NEUTRAL IN
THE BILL THAT ONE AND THAT
EXACT LANGUAGE WENT INTO THE
READ REINTRODUCTION OF THE BILL
THIS YEAR SB TIME BECAUSE OF
THE DIFFERENT VERSION LAST
YEAR- AND- I JUST WANNA LET YOU
LIVE OUT HOLDS I MEAN WE STILL
HAVE PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE TO.
WORK IN A SAFE ENVIRONMENT SO
FAR THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT THAT WAS L. STANDARD I MEAN
THE WORKPLACE SAFETY
PROTECTIONS ARE OFTEN A DOZEN
CHANGES AT ALL THAT DOES IT YOU
KNOW SOMETHING WE HAVE A-
CONVERSATION ABOUT ABOUT WAGES
AND I'M NOT AS CONCERNED WE
WORKED WITH THE TRADE ON OVER
THE YEARS- BUT THESE ARE
BECAUSE THERE'S A SMALLER
PROJECT WE TYPICALLY HAVE NOT
PUT THOSE WAGE REQUIREMENTS
AND- FOR PROJECTS TEN UNDER. AT
THAT IS THAT A LATER START
ANYWAY BUT I APPRECIATE THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE A
PLACE BUT THAT'S NOT A
CONVERSATION FOR THIS TYPE OF
BAIL- YOU KNOW THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT IS COVERED AT A
LATER TIME BUT- I DO APPRECIATE
THAT- BUT THINK I THINK. IT I
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
THE AT WORK COMMENT ICON THREAD
IN MOST OF THE- CAN THAT I HAD
SAID YOU VERY. FOR YOUR FOR
YOUR BILL AND BRING SPORT
CENTER FOR YOUR- I DO HAVE A
QUESTION A SENATOR WIENER- IT
DOES SAY IN IN THE ACTUAL
ANALYSIS HERE ON. OF THE NEW
BILL THAT IT'S- TRANSIT RICH
AREA JOBS RICH AREA OR ND
URBAN FIGHT AND URBAN INFILL
SITE PROBABLY MAKES MORE SENSE
BUT WHEN WE REACH OUT TO
SUBURBIA. ESPECIALLY IN THE
AREA THAT I LIVE THERE'S A
CONCERN THAT THIS BILL- IF YOU
COMBINE IT WITH THE DENSITY
BONUS- YOU'RE LOOKING OUT
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
DENSIFICATION IN A NUMBER OF
RESIDENTIAL AREAS IF YOU HAVE
AREAS WHERE THERE'S A VACANT
LOTS AND WE DO HAVE THAT. IN A
NUMBER OF MY COMMUNITY SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS SIMPLY HOW
IT IS THIS INTERFACE WITH THE
DENSITY BONUS LAWS THAT HAVE
BEEN PASSED SOME YARD IN THIS
SESSION AND SOME OF THE PAST
SESSIONS IF THE DEVELOPER CAME
IN AND WANTED TO DO. YOU KNOW
THE TEN UNITS THROUGHOUT THE
CITY TO AGREE TO THAT BUT ALSO
WANTED TO APPLY DENSITY BONUS-
YES AND YOU'RE RIGHT THE IN
ADDITION TO AN INFILL IT'S- THE
HIGH QUALITY TRANSIT AREA AND-
JOB RICHER. FUNDS SO THE A
DEVELOPER COULD BY DENSITY
BONUS- TO THIS PRODUCT JUST
LIKE ANY. MULTI UNIT PROJECT
TYPICALLY SMALL MULTI UNIT
DON'T NECESSARILY PENCIL WELL
FOR DENSITY BONUS SO YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A CERTAIN SCALE
TYPICALLY- SO YOU NORMALLY I
DON'T KNOW THAT YOU WOULD EVER
SEE A DENSITY BONUS TRIGGERED
ON A LIKE A FOUR OR FIVE UNIT
BUILDING. MAYBE SOMEONE HAS
DONE IT AT SOME POINT BUT
THAT'S PRETTY RARE- BUT A CITY
COULD- COULD AT LEAST IN PART
COMPENSATE FOR THAT THIS
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE CITY TO GO
UP TO TEN UNITS. RATED TEN TEN
IS THE MAXIMUM THE CITY COULD
YOU JUST BE TIME ZONE FOR FOUR
UNITS ARE FIVE UNITS ARE THREE
UNITS OR SEVEN OR TEN OR
WHATEVER THEY WANT. SO IF A
CITY IS CONCERNED OVER GOING TO
OVERTIME AND THEN THE DENSITY
BONUS COULD TAKE YOU UP TO
THIRTEEN UNITS OR SOMETHING THE
CITY BANK RECAP AT SIX OR SEVEN
TO COMPETENT TO THE CITY WOULD.
WE TRY TO PROVIDE FEXIBILITY
FOR THE CITY'S TO ENVISION WHAT
THIS WILL ULTIMATELY. LOOK LIKE
A MAN AND AGAIN THE WHOLE ALL
HERE. IS TO MAKE CITY LIVES
EASIER. SO THEY CAN CHIU- THEIR
OWN DESK IN THIS. WHEN FORCE
THEM TO DO IT. BUT I THINK
THAT'S OF SIMPLY. GOOD
COMPONENT OF THIS BUT I DO.
RAISE MY USUAL CONCERN IS WHEN
YOU START DOING GASIFICATION.
AND YOU TAKE AWAY- HIS
SPECIALLY IN THE AREAS LET'S
SAY THEY'RE TRANSIT RICH. UP
IRVINE IS A GREAT. EXAMPLE OF
TRANSIT RICH IS A JOBCENTRE BUT
IS VERY RESIDENTIAL AND YOU
WOULD BE ELIMINATING-
REQUIREMENT FOR PARKING. AND
I'D LIKE TO TRAVEL FROM OF
THOSE AREAS AND SEE WHAT THAT
HAS DONE ALL THE PARKING OF ALL
OVER THE STREETS. AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY IN UNIVERSITY TOWNS
LEVINE AGAIN. OF THE DAY ARE
DOUBLING UP IN THESE UNITS
BECAUSE IT'S VERY AFFORDABLE
BUT THEY ALL HAVE CARS. YOU
FIVE HARDLY FIND OF KIDS IN
THAT AREA- THAT AGE THAT DON'T
BECAUSE- YOU NEED THEM. SO THAT
REMAINS MY MAJOR CONCERN WITH
THE DENSIFICATION ALL THAT IS
TAKEN PLACE AND YOU KNOW OUR
HOUSING- THEORY HERE AND WE
REALLY NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AND I THINK YOU HEARD ME
MANY TIMES I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT. BECAUSE IN MY CITY WE'VE
LOST LIVES OF CHILLED CHILDREN
OF HAVE. LOST THEIR LIVES
GOING. IN THESE AREAS WHERE IF.
YOU KNOW CONDOMINIUMS- AND SOME
APARTMENTAREAS GOING THROUGH-
YOU KNOW PARK CARS HERE AND
THEY'RE EVERYWHERE AND THEY
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES SO. I'M
GONNA STICK WITH THAT BUT I DO-
SAY THANK YOU FOR MAKING IT.
VOLUNTARY BECAUSE I THINK OUR
CITY COUNCILS ON THE BIG
ADVOCATE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND I THINK THEY DO A GOOD JOB.
IN TAKING A LOOK AT WHAT IS
GOING TO BE. IN A RIGHT FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES FEIST RIGHT
AND CERTAINLY LOCATION RIGHT.
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF AREA AND
HERE THAT- THE AUDIENCE
DISCRETIONARY ONCE YOU SAY
YOU'RE GOING TO DO A DENSITY
BONUS AND WE'RE REQUIRED TO YOU
COULD HAVE A TEN UNIT THING AND
NOW. THEY WANT TO PUT FOR UNITS.
IN ADDITION THAT ARE AFFORDABLE
AND ANY MEDIA REALLY OPENS UP
THE TO DO. BY AND ALL THE OTHER
SO I WILL BE A- TO THE BUT I
KNOW THAT YOU. VERY HARD ON THE
PHONE. WE AND I KNOW THAT. YOU
HAVE CASH THAT EQUALS UP THEIR
SIDE. THE WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS IT THAT TOUGH KNOWING
ALL WE HAVE A TIME ISSUE HERE
AND- ESPECIALLY WITH FOR YOUR
NEXT BILL. I JUST THINK IF
THERE'S NO OTHER. COMMENTS
UNLESS YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND. I KNOW I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS THAT  THINK ARE
I THINK I'LL TAKE THAT AS MY
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
OFFER I WILL. IS THAT IS THAT
YOU WOULD. YOU LIKE TO MAKE
YOUR CLOTHES SUCH A CLOSE. OKAY
MAN. WILL THE ROLL. DID WE HAVE
A MOTION. SORRY WE HAVE A
MOTION OR DID WE HAVE A MOTION
I THOUGHT WE HAD EARLIER MOTION
BUT- DO WE HAVE A MOTION. I'M
ABOUT THE MOVE IN MOVE BY
SENATOR CAFIERO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL TEN
BY SENATOR WIENER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE BATES NO BATES NO
CABALLERO. CABALLERO AYE
CORTESE AYE CORTESE AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE THE TROUBLE HI THE
CHERNOBYL HI SKINNER. SKINNER I
AM BURKE BUT CASKEY HI
TELESCOPII. SEVEN ONE THAT
BILLS OUT THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
WE WILL NOW MOVES TO THE SENATE
BILL FOR SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR WIENER- PLEASE PRESENT
YOUR REALTOR JULIA. FIVE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MANABADI SIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ON THE SP
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN IS THAT-
CALIFORNIA HOUSING DATA ACT.
CALIFORNIA HAS ADOPTED A NUMBER
OF HOUSING LAWS IN RECENT YEARS
TO HELP ADDRESS OUR HOUSING
CRISIS. BUT UNFORTUNATELY- DATA
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
THESE LAWS IS SPORADIC AT BEST
AND QUITE LIMITED. AND SO THERE
ARE TIMES WHEN WE STRUGGLE TO
ACTUALLY QUANTIFY. EXACTLY HOW
EFFECTIVE THESE LAWS ARE HOW
THEY'RE BEING IMPLEMENTED IN
FRANK ABOUT THE TO IS IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS DEBATE. IN TERMS OF
ASSESSING IS THIS LOG DOING
WHAT WE INTENDED. IT TO DOING
MORE THAN WE INTENDED AS A
LESSON WERE INTENDED EFFECT
CREATING- UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OR IS IT HITTING
THE NAIL RIGHT ON THE HEAD- WE
REALLY HAVE TROUBLE DOING THAT
EVALUATION WE HAVEN'T FOR SOME.
LAWS BUT NOT FOR OTHERS. SB
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN EXPANDS
CALIFORNIA'S DATA COLLECTION
REGARDING- THE IMPACTS AND
EFFECTIVENESS OR LACK THEREOF
OF STATE HOUSING LAWS- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO STRENGTHEN OUR
HOUSING DATA COLLECTIONS OF THE
PUBLIC AND POLICY MAKERS. I CAN
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING-
SO. THIS WILL ALSO BE HELPFUL
FOR STATE AGENCIES FOR
RESEARCHERS FOR ADVOCATES FOR
OUR OWN LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- TO BE ABLE TO. ADVOCATE
AND TO ADVISE US ON CHANGES IN
HOUSING LAW- SB FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
ADDING A NUMBER OF REQUIREMENTS
TO THE ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORT
KNOWN AS THE APR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ALREADY
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT TO HUD EACH
YEAR. AND RELATIONS ARE HOUSING
ELEMENTS JUST TO BE CLEAR
CITIES ALREADY HAVE TO PROVIDE
THIS ANNUAL REPORT- IN THE
ASSEMBLY ODDS OF SOME
ADDITIONAL DATA THAT THEY
PROVIDE- WITH A REPORT- FIVE SO
FOR EXAMPLE- IT WILL REQUIRE-
THAT CITIES BY THE LOCATION AND
TOTAL NUMBER OF DEVELOPMENTS
APPROVED BUILDING PERMITS
ISSUED- UNITS CONSTRUCTED-
PURSUANT TO STREAMLINING
REQUIREMENTS- ARE FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. PROJECT
ROOM KEY AND SO FORTH- IN. A
CITIES WANT TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ABOUT MITIGATION
FEES OWNING ORDINANCES AND
DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS WHICH ARE
ALREADY REQUIRED TO REPORT
UNDER PREVIOUS LAW- SO
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT LAW IT'LL HELP US
MAKE BETTER DECISIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL SB
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN- WITH ME IN
SPIRIT. OVER THE PHONE POSTED
BY TODAY ARE THOSE MERON TAKING
CALIFORNIA YIMBY ONE OF OUR
SPONSORS AND MICHAEL IN FROM
SPUR OR OTHER. SPONSORS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THEIR ONLINE I
BELIEVE- PLEASE SUCK RESENT
YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER MARATHI I
BELIEVE YOU'RE UP FIRST. GOOD
MORNING ARE ACTING RATHER MADAM
ABOUT YOUR MEMBERS LUPRON THANK
GOD WITH CALIFORNIA BE HERE ON
THURSDAY THAT HE WAS SEVENTY
SEVEN I WITH A FRIEND THAT
WORKS BURKE. I LIKE CENTER
WIENER MENTIONED AT THE FORTY
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN CREEK THE
LION IDEA TO STANDARDS FOR MANY
OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING LAWS YOU
ARE. VERY STREAMLINING CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO REPORT PROGRESS ON HOUSING
EVERY YEAR AS A PART OF THE
ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS. AND
THE ATP. WELL ADD TO THIS
REPORT AND PASSED IT OUT THANK
YOU BEING APPROVED PURSUANT
CLASSIFIED. I REALLY THINK THAT
THE AND WHILE US TO. IN MANY
CASES THE FIRST TIME THE SIX
FROM THE BUT BEEN ON THE BILL
FOR THIRTY. HELLO OUR- IN OUR
BOND TO WORK WITH THEIR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IMPROVE LOCAL IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE- TO ALLOW
THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE CHANGES
THE PRODUCT WORK WHICH IS A
COMPLEX OUTCOMES THAT ARE
DIFFERENT. FROM WHAT WE CAN
OBSERVE HAPPENING. AND ALLOW
OUR ACTIVISTS MAKE BETTER
INFORMED. DECISIONS AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AND HELP
THEM WORK WITH ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT AND THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA. THE BILL
GIVES LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND EACH
YEAR UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE
GOOD JOB REPORTING THE DATA. IT
WILL IN MOST CASES ONLY REQUIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ANSWER A
SIMPLE YES OR NO QUESTION. ON
THE PROJECTS THE LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT IS YOUR BOARDING-
ABOUT IT APR IT COULD A
PERMANENT PROJECT RECEIVED. ANY
OF THE INCLUDED THAT THE STATE.
IS GOING TO LIVE IN AN APR.
EIGHTEENTH APR. THIS IS A
SIMPLE GOOD GOVERNMENT REFORMS
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK.
THANK YOU AND ARE NOW STOP.
SUPPORTER HILLS MICHAEL LANE
YOU ON THE LINE MICHAEL. YES I
AM SURE BAKER MEMBERS MIKE LANE
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION A PUBLIC POLICY
THINK TANK KNOWN AS FOR. AS THE
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN IS
INTENTIONALLY DESIGNED TO BE A
LIGHT TOUCH WITH LITTLE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN. THE DATA
PROPOSED TO BE REPORTED TO H.
C. DETERMINE EXISTING APR
PROCESSES INFORMATION BUT
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS ALREADY
HAVE INTRACTABLE CONSIDERING
DEVELOPING APPLICATIONS HOWEVER
THIS IS CRITICAL INFORMATION
NEVER POLICYMAKERS AND PUBLIC
STAKEHOLDERS AND RESEARCHERS
STATEWIDE. WEATHER WISE HAVE TO
MAKE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST
SEARCH THROUGH PAPER FILES
STAFF REPORT CITY COUNCIL AND
PLANNING COMMISSION AGENDAS AND
THEN HAND CO DATA INTO
DATABASES ALL JURISDICTION BY
JURISDICTION. SB COURSE SEVEN
SEVEN IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
OUR STATE HOUSING POLICY COULD
BE GROUNDED IN AN INFORMED BY
BETTER AND MORE COMPLETE
INFORMATION AND TO MEASURE.
RESULTS WE ARE CAN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LANE WILL NOW
GO TO ADDITIONAL ALL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT AND I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE APPROACHING. HERE IN OUR
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. THEN
WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
AND I DO NOT SEE ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY. STEPPING UP SO WE
WILL NOW GO TO THOSE WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OF AS- A MATTER MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT SO WE MAY BEGAN.
THANK YOU YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY N. Q. OUR
FIRST WILL COME FROM ONE OF TWO
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TIMER
SKYPE THE PROPOSAL WE CAN HEAR
YOU. RIGHT NEXT TO THE LINE OF
THREE FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. JENNIFER SPECTRUM OFF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE OF THREE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
DAVID LARKIN CALLING WITH
NINETY CAN BE CONTENT DISTRICT
THIRTEEN IN SUPPORT OF SIMPLE.
THANK YOU ONE THREE SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I WOULD
START WITH THE HAVE BEEN ACTION
OCEANS WHAT WHAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE THREE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I THEIR
NATASHA GOLD WALKED OUT OF
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE ONE
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TO BE MORE SHAUNA COMING OUT
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES ON
BEHALF OF PROSPECT EVERYONE
ABUNDANT HOUSING LA SUPPORT
THANKS. THANK YOU FIND AT THREE
FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
NOT A LOT LIKE I'M PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT AT HOME HAVE ATTRACTED
ID CALIFORNIA THE COUNCIL
INFILL BUILDERS CAN HELP
PROPERTY MANAGING PARTNER AND
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING.
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHY NOT THREE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON OPPORTUNE
AMERICAN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NINE THREE SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
KATHY BEANS WITH- YOU'D BE
ACTION AND CRITICAL FOR
EVERYONE IN THE COURT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THREE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CAROLINE AND I AM CONFIDENT
THAT BY EVERYONE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ANTI POISON. THANK
YOU THREE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ARE YOU A
STRONG OPEN I AM CALLING WITH
EAST BAY FOR EVERYONE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KEVIN
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU TO NINETY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SCHREIBER WHOSE MIND WITH
GENERATION HOUSING AND SUMMIT
COUNTY ALSO STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NINE THREE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
ALSO INCLUDES CULVER CITY AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOHN LEVEL ON THE
APPLE IN. TWENTY DOLLARS THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN. THE UC
CALIFORNIA THERE'D BE LIKE
THOUSAND PORTLAND THERE AND THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS. OR ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU TWO TO TEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS JORDAN
CRIMES ON BEHALF OF AN INFILL
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE FOUR SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT TO TWELVE DO YOU
HAVE A FIVE MINUTE. EXCELLENT A
LINE OF THREE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS BEN AYE IT CROW CALLING IN
TODAY WITH ABUNDANT HOUSING
WALKED AND LOOKED INTO THE PORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
AVAILABLE THREE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS THAT GOING I'M CALLING WITH
IN THE ACTION IN THE DAY AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
THREE ELEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SERRA OGILVY WITH SAN FRANCISCO
YANBIAN STRONG SUPPORT TODAY AT
BEST BEFORE SEVENTY THOUSAND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS
OVER A LIVE THREE SEVENTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN YOU HAVE
IT. YES YEAH RAPANA TOLD ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CRUZ SB AND
AGAIN BE ACTION IN CONCORD.
THANK YOU NEXT ON THE LINE OF
THREE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI DRESCHER BURKE WHO
SOUTH PASADENA RESIDENT
RESPONSIBLE GROWTH WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU AND THE LAST
FINING Q. WILL COME FROM NINE
TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH I'D RATHER LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN FRANCISCO TO
BE. THINKING THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A MAN MODERATOR THEN
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. AND I DO NOT SEE
THAT WE HAVE THE LEAD
OPPOSITION SO WE WILL ALL LOOK
TO ANYONE AND- FORTY TWO OH
THREE I DO NOT SEE ANYONE HERE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
MOVING OVER TO RAM TWENTY
FORTY. I SEE NO ONE NOT WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN THAT ROOM SO WE
WILL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCING THOSE ON THE
PHONE. WHO QUEUED UP AND UP
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR THEM-
THAT A MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY SHOW
FIVE IN Q. OVER TRYING THREE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
FIRST ON BEHALF OF CATALYST
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WHICH
FURTHERS THE BURDEN ON THE CITY
STAFF WITHOUT PLACING AN EQUAL
AMOUNT ON DEVELOPERS WE
APOLOGIZE. THANK YOU ARE BUYING
TWO OR THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JULIE TO HELP
THEM BECOME BY MAYOR AND WITH
CALIFORNIA WINES OF LOCAL
ELECTED. WE APPROACH. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THREE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
CHRISTY QUARTERLY WITH KATELYN
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU
RYAN TO FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I DAVID WHEATLEY WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S CITIES FOR A LOCAL
CONTROL STRONGLY OPPOSED UNTIL
THE RATIO OF ONE HOUSE A LUXURY
HOUSE OCCUPANTS BY BLOCK IS
PROVIDED. THANK YOU RYAN TO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YEAH GO AHEAD. THIS IS
EMILY GABEL LUDDY PATHWAY-
BURBANK BOULEVARD CALIFORNIA.
THANKS BILLS LIKE TRONIC
DASHBOARD IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
CITY SO THAT THE RECORD OF
THESE PRODCTS CAN BE MADE
TRANSPARENT AND PUBLIC AND THAT
PASSWORD SHOULD ALSO INCLUDE
PER CAPITA DEMAND ON SERVICES.
LIKE SCHOOLS POLICE FIRE WATER
INFLUENCE. THAT WAY EVERYBODY
CAN SEE. ALL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO THAT CAN.
THANK YOU I'M THREE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS A GREAT BURGER WITH CATALYST
IN OPPOSITION FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU I'M MEHR
MODERATOR WITH NOLAN
ADDITIONALLY WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION WE WILL UP BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
LOOK FOR ANY ON HEALTH UP
SENATOR WIENER. I MEAN SKEWS ME
FEDERAL I GOT FEE FROM AMONG
PAGE SEVEN OF THE STAFF REPORT
AND WITH LIST OUT A THROUGH G.
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE RICH- AS PART OF THE
ANNUAL. PROGRESS REPORT EVERITT
NO PROBLEMS WOULD. BE THROUGH
G. I WAS- HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR
YOUR- PROPONENTS SAY THAT THIS
IS A LIGHT TOUCH BECAUSE I WAS
CONCERNED WHEN I READ THROUGH
IT THAT THIS WAS GOING TO BE. A
FULL EMPLOYMENT ACT FOR TITLE
SEARCHES ON ALL THE DIFFERENT
PARCELS IN A CITY THAT MAY HAVE
THE RESTRICTION WHETHER IT WAS
A LAGUNA. THE GAL OR SAN JOSE
OR SAN FRANCISCO BECAUSE IT WAS
THE ANNEX BIG SECTION OR THE
EVERY REQUIREMENTS AND EACH
PARCEL BY THE CITY OR THE
COUNTY TO SPECIAL DISTRICT-
THAT YOU KNOW ONCE UPON A TIME
YOU DIDN'T HAVE CATTLE RAISING
OR YOU COULDN'T DO THIS THERE
WERE SOME PRO PROHIBITIONS THAT
WERE PUT IN LONG LONG AGO- SO
THAT WAS ONE QUESTION AND THEN.
IF WE'RE ALREADY SENDING ANNUAL
REPORTS DEFICIENT AB MAYBE OR
IN AND THAT INCOMPLETE. IT ALSO
REQUIRES THAT YOU SEND THE
CURRENT ONE IN THE FINAL THE
FIVE LAST ONES ARE YOU
ANTICIPATING THAT THE THIS IS
CURRENT IN FIVE PREVIOUS ANNUAL
REPORTS WOULD THAT BE AMENDED
REPORTS FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
SO THAT WASN'T CLEAR IF YOU
COULD. COMMENT CIRCLE THIRTY
SEVEN ON THE GIRL LIKE AND
SEARCH. TITLES THIS IS ABOUT.
ACTIONS OF THE CITIES ARE
TAKING OR NOT TAKING ON
PROJECTS WHAT YOU KNOW WITH A
CERTAIN SECTION ARE INVOKING
HER. IF THEY'RE REJECTING OR
ACCEPTING SB THIRTY FIVE
APPLICATIONS THINGS LIKE THAT-
AND IN TERMS OF NO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO RETROACTIVELY CHANGE
OUR PREVIOUS APR IS. THIS IS
FOR GOING FORWARD THEY HAVE TO
ADD. ADDITIONAL MATERIAL. YES-
I WOULD JUST SAY MICHAEL IN-AGAIN WHAT WAS FOR. IT HAS
BURST- THERE'S A COMMITMENT FOR
NOTICES NOTES THERE. IS AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
NINETY WAS ALREADY SIGNED INTO
LAW WHICH HAS REQUIREMENTS AND
WHAT WERE SEEN AS A BEST
PRACTICE MAJOR ADDICTIONS AND
CRADLE LANDING. PAGES ON A
WEBSITE WHERE THEY'RE CLEAN
THAT INFORMATION THAT'S
REQUIRED BREAKING FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE AND I WOULD SEE
WHERE THEY WOULD JUST PROVIDE A
LINK TAKES YOU TO CONFIRM THAT
THEIR- CALIFORNIA STATE LAW AND
THEN THAT LOOK AT THOSE AND
THEN WE HAVE A CENTRAL
CLEARINGHOUSE FOR THE
INFORMATION AND MAKE IT EASIER
FOR EVERYONE TO SEE. INSTEAD OF
HAVING TO GO TO CHURCH
JURISDICTION WEBSITE NEXT CITY
ALSO THE MASTER LIST WITH
LINKS. ARE SMART BECAUSE I KNOW
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE POSING A
BECAUSE THEY THINK IT'S SOME
NEFARIOUS EFFORT TO DO
SOMETHING I MEAN THIS IS. ITS
DATA AND DATA CAN BE HELPFUL OR
HARMFUL TO ANY POINT OF VIEW
BRADLEY THERE COULD YOU COULD
AS A TO THE RESIDENTS YOU WANT
TO KNOW. WHAT IS MY CITY
COUNCIL OR PLANNING DEPARTMENT
DOING FOR PERMITS. BUT YOU
MIGHT BE SOMEBODY WANT TO SEE A
TIME MORE HOUSING SO YOU'RE I'M
HAPPY THAT THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT IS ACTING A CERTAIN
WAY. YOU COULD BE SOMEONE WHO'S
CONCERNED ABOUT MORE HOUSING IN
YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD. AND YOU WANT
TO TRANSPARENCY. TO SEE WHAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING RIGHT
NOW. BECAUSE THE DATA IS
LIMITED. JUST READ OF A CAN.
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A I DON'T
EVEN. HOW THEY WERE. GET A LIST.
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO DO HAND
SEARCHES. WE WANT TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR EVERYONE WHATEVER
THEIR POINT OF VIEW IT'S- AN
IDEA. MADAM CHAIR IF I COULD
THAT THE IDEA THAT YOU HAVE
NEXUS STUDIES THAT MAYBE YOU
NEVER SEND IT TO H. E. D. D. OF
ANNEX A STUDY ON YOUR IMPACT
FEES THAT YOU COMPLETED. IT
THREE YEARS AGO AND SOMEHOW HCD
DOESN'T HAVE IT. THIS NOW WOULD
MAKE THAT REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
GET THAT DATA. AND HOPEFULLY.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE WOULD
HAVE YOU PUT IT ON YOUR WEBSITE
TOO SO THAT. THE CITIZENS OF
AND I KNOW HE'S GOING TO READ
IT BUT- OKAY. THAT'S IT THAT'S
ALL MY QUESTIONS. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS IS A REMOTE
OR THE NATURE. OF A HERO. THANK
YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM HAIR I. HAVE A COMMENT.
AND THEN I'M READY TO MOVE THE
BILL IF IT'S- APPROPRIATE- I
REALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AND- I'M ONE OF THE REASONS IS
BECAUSE IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET THIS KIND OF INFORMATION
FROM CITIES UNLESS YOU. YOU YOU
ASK FOR IT DIRECTLY. AND EVEN
THEN IT'S DIFFICULT TO GET-
THIS WOULD REQUIRE THE CITY TO
PREPARE A DOCUMENT THAT WOULD
GO TO EACH CD. IN WHICH CASE
THE CITIZENS WOULD GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THAT IS PART
OF THE CITY COUNCIL PACKET SO
IT'S REALLY. A SUNSHINE TYPE
OF. A BILL THAT WILL GIVE. THE
LOCAL RESIDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE WITH CITY COUNCILS ARE
DOING AS WELL SO- I LIKE THE
BILL I LIKE THE- THE DATA THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE PRODUCING AND
SO I MOVED BUT- WE MOVE THE
BILL. FOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THEN WE DO HAVE A MOTION. HOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU BYE BYE MY
FOR ONE OF MY FORMER LEGEND TO
SEVEN ON HOUSING- THERE WAS A
BILL AYE ALONG OUT THERE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SB THIRTY FIVE
THAT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE- AND
SHE USED TO REFER TO HERSELF AS
THE SB THIRTY FIVE HOTLINE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE CALL AND SAY HEY
WE'RE DOING IN SB THIRTY FIVE
PROJECT WANNA LET YOU KNOW AND
IT WAS GREAT LIKE WE WOULD SEE
SHE WOULD KEEP A LIST PREVENT
ONE POINT I SAID RESIDENT MUST
FIGURE OUT WHERE THIS IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED. AND IT WAS LIKE
HER AD HOC LIST AND THEN WE
HAVE TO CALL PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS THE ONES THAT WERE
COOPERATIVE TO SAY HEY COULD
YOU GIVE US A SPREADSHEET. AND
I REALIZE I'M LIKE WHAT WHAT
ARE WE DOING HERE THIS SHOULD
JUST BE LIKE STANDARD DATA
THAT'S PRODUCE WE DON'T NEED A-
SB THIRTY FIVE HOTLINE AND
SCOTT WENNER'S OFFICE AND SO
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL. IS
IMPORTANT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WINNER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
HI THERE I BATES. I'M NOT
ROOTING IT'S NOT VOTING
CABALLERO. CABALLERO CORTESE BY
FOR KATIE I MCGUIRE- CHARBEL I
STRUCTURE ABOUT SKINNER HI
SKINNER I AM BURKE CASKEY I
HEALTHCARE I. SIX VOTES. OF OUT
ON CALL OF TO PLACE THE BILL ON
CALL FOR SENATOR ON PLACE THE
BILL ON CALL. I'M YEAH OKAY SO-
NOT TO BE OKAY THANK YOU OKAY
SO WE'VE NOW GONE THROUGH ALL
THE BILLS CAR WE HAVE I WANT TO
THANK MEMBERS FOR PERSEVERANCE
TODAY WE HAVE THREE BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL COM AND WE'RE GOING
TO REOPEN- THE ROLE IN EACH OF
THOSE- SO WE'LL START WE'LL GO
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
THREE NINETY ONE AND BY CENTER
MAN- WILL- WILL LOOK AT SOME
OF. THESE- CALL THE OPTIMUM.
THIS IS SB THREE NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR MA'AM THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A BANDIT BUT FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. UMBERG SIX SELF OKAY.
SIX NINE SIX SEVEN. OKAY SIX
NOTHING- THAT BILL IS OUT ON
BOTH SIDES WITH THREE NINETY
ONE IS OUT FIVE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR S. B. TWO NINETY BY
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THIS IS SENATE BILL TO NINETY
BY SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. SENATE
MCGUIRE. UMBERG SIX NOTHING
OKAY SIX TO NOTHING SIX ONE I'M
SORRY SIX TO ONE FOR SB TWO
NINETY AND THAT BILL IS OUT-
AND THEN ITEM. NUMBER SIX SB
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS IS A
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR WINNER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MCGUIRE. I'M
BURKE SEVEN L. SEVEN NOTHING
ELSE BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN IS
OUT ANYTHING ELSE THAT WE NEED
TO OPEN THE WRONG ONE OKAY SO
ALL BILLS OR ELSE IT'S GREAT IN
THE RULES ARE ALL CLOSE- THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING- YOU CAN DO SO THROUGH
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US. AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PERSEVERANCE
TODAY THAT INCLUDES OUR AGENDA
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
IS A TERMS.